Don't tell him. Call Four, three, two
Mli Tom, papa, Joe
Rogan and see you buddy.
Good to see you cracking. Lacking I
Nah, not too much cruising around.
We were talking about old
body's falling apart. Yeah.
Got a stem cell shot in my shoulder
that's killing me right now. Yeah,
I can tell you're in
pain. Oh yeah. One shot.
Several in both shoulders and this
is not like anything like that.
It's like a serious injury,
but there've been annoying me lately,
so I said fuck it.
Let me just go in there.
Every time I've done it it's
made me feel better. Right.
How often do you have to go?
I've been doing it like once
every six months. Right?
Yeah. That's what happened to it. And then
it kind of is okay for awhile and yeah.
Right. And once every six months seems
to keep me in, but it's expensive.
So is it not,
is not curing whatever it gets his
healing it being a moron. Right.
And going back to working out hard.
But we were just saying is that soft
tissue heals like this is a soft tissue
issue.
Yeah.
Soft tissue is one of the best things
for things like stem cells to therapy
because you can actually
regenerate tissue. Right.
And it can heal things where it gets
a real problem with my friend Miriam
Nakamoto, she brought over
those, uh, snacks, those
bags of snacks or were there,
there was a little snack
company. She's a, a,
a multiple time world Moitai
champion Boy Moy, Tai Muay Thai,
Thai boxing, Muay Thai. No, never
heard of that. Nope. You're so,
if so, uh, what are white? You're white.
You're also like a, a non jock.
Well, I was a jock my whole life.
What would you do? I played a
football. Did you? Oh, that's right.
I believe football forever and track
and a bunch of stuff that you fucked.
Then I stopped. Did you fucking
body up at all? Uh, no. Not too bad.
My shoulders a little bit. My shoulder's
a little, but uh, that's pretty much it.
My, my knees, you know,
like I run a lot now.
I've been running off for the
last couple months and uh, what,
what brought that on? I just
want to be in better shape. Yeah,
I want to feel better. I dropped
like burn off 17 rounds. Yeah,
exactly. I was like, baby, maybe.
Yeah. Your face looks thinner,
man. Yeah, it looks good.
Yeah. That's awesome man.
That's a cool thing once you get
going, right? Yeah. At that momentum,
that's what's up. Well, you know,
it's really was up was I was kind of
cruising along and just like we lost five
pounds.
It just kind of like hanging around and
then I realized I'm working out like
this workout that I'm doing is what?
A bit of a warmup when I was an athlete.
Right.
This wasn't even a been a warm up and
I'm like, oh, that was pretty good.
And I'm just like,
I have to stop being a sissy and try
and really push it a little more.
Let's get a trainer, Eh,
I don't like intimacy. Oh,
that's real. Well, you
know what else you can do?
There's actually apps where you can
follow an app and the APP will put you
through a workout. Oh yeah, yeah. There's
several of them now. They're really good.
Oh cool.
A bunch of really good ones.
I don't have any affiliation with any
of them. I'm not naming any of them,
but yeah, you can. Um, you can,
you can even get a yoga one.
You can get a 90 minute yoga one,
right.
Just do yoga and it talks you
through the poses. It's great. Yeah.
I used to do yoga all the time,
but I feel like I've got to, uh,
I feel I have to shift into lifting
weights again because I've just been
dropping now, but I just feel like, you
know, a little bit. I don't want to be,
I don't want her hands. I don't want to
give a guy like at the pool with no arms.
You know what I mean?
So many people have motivated themselves
by going to the beach or the pool with
very little clothes on it. I
thought about Fox summertime. Fuck.
People are gonna know.
Yeah, right. Exactly.
I reveal my secrets and then we're
going to know what disgusts me about,
yeah, this is my glass. Look at
it. This is my laziness. Luck.
This is what I did all winter. This is
my poor food choices right here. Luck.
This is drinking upper the upper part.
Yeah. This is the part right on the sides.
But I really just, but then when I
started getting after and being like,
don't be such a sissy, like trip workout,
try and push it. Then you want it.
Then I want it to do it more.
Then I got into it. Then I'm like,
all right let's go. Now I'm going
further and quicker. But uh,
this is all been cardio.
All Cardio.
What about just body
weight stuff like you know,
I mean it's not a bad idea to
start off with body weight.
First of all pushups because you
haven't really done much like that.
And while it's Chin ups,
push ups and the body weight
squats really don't need much else.
He really not really, I've been
doing more pushups, density,
ferocious workout in with
Change Grip pushups, Chin ups,
body weight squats.
Just to just those things.
Does that mean I have to get
with one of those Chin up bars?
It goes in the doorway that get a real
one though. Cause those things fall on.
People don't know. Ones that
hang, folks. Listen to me.
Those ones that hang on the door, the
door Jamb, I used to work construction.
Those fucking things are not
designed for you hanging on him.
Now I have a little tiny nails and people
like me probably installed them and
sometimes you don't hit a stud.
That little tiny nail is going right
into the fucking dry wall and you're
hanging that thing over there and
it's pulling on that soccer. No.
Then I'll messed my shoulder up.
I'll beat that fucker's that
drill into the side of the door.
You know what I'm saying?
The ones that they go right in the side,
four screws on each side, that'll
hold your weight. All right.
I don't hold your weight. I'll get that.
That want to work because it's pulling.
You're pulling down on the
wood. We, those things are,
it's like sitting on the wood,
you know those ones that it
is a recipe for a broken neck.
I feel like that thing was in like
every eighties movie. Yeah. I mean,
I'm sure they have good ones to do
that. I'm sure that, yeah, sure.
But you should really check
out your fucking moldings.
First moldings a pull and I just lay on
the ground and do some pushups. Yeah,
but real chin up bar man.
A real chin up bar is, is,
I mean if you just got one in a park, just
go to the fucking park. You're outside.
They'll a lot of parks have like those
bars a little set up so you could do
counseling. Yeah. Nobody
ever, I'm are no joke.
Those are great for working out and I
know they seem too simple. They seem like,
oh ladies with Wesco or for their role, I
go to Nautilus. I don't need this. Right,
exactly.
I do my leg extensions on Nautilus.
I got my membership I use once a month.
Bodyweight squats seem easy
when you do three. Yeah,
but when you do a hundred they
become very fucking hard. Right.
When you get to like 70 and you're like,
Holy Shit, you feel that burn baby.
And he'd start counting down in tents.
I remember doing pushups
when we were played football
and you would do, you know,
200 who'd be like 200 breaking motto row.
No. Break them out and do it in a row.
They would, we do like 30 and then
split them up and uh, you know,
there was a big time workout and now I'm
doing like 25 I'm like I'm good for a
couple of days. It's hard man. It is hard
getting anywhere more than 30 pushups.
It's like Whoa, shit
starts getting crazy. Yeah.
It was a lot of pushing.
Yeah.
To like your body has to be
conditioned for that and if it's not,
it lets you know you're like dirty
arms start shaking.
The funniest part is hockey around 19
though, you get to like 1819 like bro,
I'm feeling fucking smooth.
It's so funny how whatever number you
have in your head is where you start to
write.
If you say I'm doing 20 you start
shaking at 18 if you say I'm doing 25 you
don't start shaking until 23 you know,
what's a real mental thing? You know,
it's really fucking cool than are gone.
Rogue makes this thing that it's a,
it's like a bamboo pole and on the end
of the pole you put a rubber straps like
a, you know, those, those, uh, bands
that you, and then from those bands,
you Hank kettlebells off
of the bamboo stick. Yes.
So as you're doing this bench was, I
can't push my lift, my right arm up.
It's all rain right now. Otherwise I'll
show you as you're doing this thing,
everything's all wobbly and everything.
Super, super wobbly because first of all,
the kettle bells hanging from
rubber, right. And the, the,
the stick is bamboo thing is super wobbly.
Right?
And as you lift weights with that, it's
really good for your stabilizing muscles.
Hold an earthquake bar, that's earthquake.
Cool. Or there's a version of it.
So it's a stabilizing watch the video
online or someone will take us offline.
Yeah, the earthquake bar. Yeah,
that's exactly what the one I have.
We have that out there.
I'll show it to you afterwards.
It's really cool because even lightweight,
like if you had to do 70 pounds,
like 35 on each side,
it's awkward for that.
That doesn't look like something
you want to use in your house.
You're going to ruin your floors. Put
rubber on the floor. Rubber on the floor.
Yup. Rubber over your house so
nothing gets ruined. Did you,
do you have grandparents who put plastic
over the furniture? Oh yeah. My Nana.
My Nana and Clifton. New Jersey. Yeah,
mine. Mine was in New York. Yeah,
they put fucking plastic over
the furniture. It was a big deal.
You spent a lot of money on that couch.
You're going to,
it's gonna [inaudible] fuse.
When I, a little kid, I'd
sit on that couch over like,
this is terrible. Especially in the
summer with your shorts and your legs.
Just be sweating it man.
They eventually got kinda like
yellowed by the sun and by use faculty.
So it was weird. Yeah. It was like, oh,
you would like put like a jacket down
and then he would sit on your jacket.
That whole generation never had comfort.
Like their beds were hard.
The pillows were Shit live through
the fucking depression, Matt.
Yeah, that's real. That
shit. People Starve to death.
This was a barbaric time where where
people were brought down to, you know,
base humanity just rival
rough and then you have like,
you have like 15 good years and then go
into World War II and they dealt with
that. So yeah, they were
like, we don't need comfort.
We're not laying around in our
sweatpants on bean bag chairs.
Well they knew the importance of being
vigilant. Right. Like we all do. You,
do you ever, do you follow? I'm
David Goggins online. David,
do you know what he is?
David Goggins is this navy seal
who now is more or less uh,
uh,
like a motivational and
a fitness influencer.
The Guy who runs broken knees,
he's a fucking savage. Yeah,
I've seen some of his clips. How many?
100 mile runs that he run in a row.
Some fucking preposterous number.
I don't want to say cause I can't remember
it all. I want to say six or seven.
But then it's like 12 or 13 of 100 mile.
Remember I don't remember at all.
But his whole thing is stay hard.
Like he'll send me a text out of nowhere.
Like just say stay hard motherfucker.
She's out there. Yeah. Cause like
first of all, if you're a navy seal,
right?
This is the pinnacle of hand to
hand combat and armed forces.
Like those motherfuckers were all
special human and then on top of those
motherfuckers been all special humans.
There's guys that can just,
just put a little of that
message out like, hey you,
you are soft as fuck compared to how
people used to be all soft as fuck.
Compare it to those World War II people.
Those stay,
you gotta stay vigilant
back then everybody had to
stay vigilant. Yeah. Yeah.
You had to deal with just day to day life,
you have to deal with what
was coming from Hitler.
What a tune in at a certain time to
find out what was happening. Yeah.
Everybody had to gather
around the TV for the news.
That was all the news you got.
That's all the news you got.
You only got an hour's worth. That was
it. They just, what the fuck was going on?
Nothing. Nothing. And they were better
on record and they say, really? What's,
I'm so tired of that. They were better
off for it. I don't need to know.
Not better off for it.
Way Better off recognizing that you're
luckier than those people having some
fucking discipline.
Watching a David Goggins Instagram clip
and get your fucking shit together top.
No, I'm not. I agree with
everything you just said.
I agree with everything you just said,
but I'm saying you're better.
They were better off not being
fed a news diet 24 hours a day.
Mentally,
mentally.
We're the first human beings that
have had to deal with this on slot.
It's a double edge sword because if you
don't get fed that you don't find out
about Julian Assange getting kicked
out of the embassy in London.
You don't find out about a million
different stories that are in the news.
It's a fun story. It's a cool story,
but do I need to know it? It's a fun,
that's a quote for you from now on. Hey,
what about Julian Assange? Tom Papa,
hands up and close. It's a
fun story. It's a cool story,
but I don't need to know it. Holy
Shit. Really. I mean, really,
you just redefined white privilege.
Well, you hit it, you hit it on the head,
lit it on fire. No, it's seriously,
what can I do about a lot
of these, you know, look,
I think it's good that information is
flowing and that moves everybody forward.
But you know, for me, sitting
in there trying to tell
some jokes and feed my kids,
it's like,
do I need to know everything,
every trouble spot going around the world.
It's like,
that is a very good question.
It's like how much responsibility do you
have to be tuned in to all the events
of the world and to act like how much
responsibility do you have outside of
voting and do you have the
responsibility to vote?
Cause there's some people that are very
interesting people that don't vote. Yeah.
You know, I don't agree
with that. Yeah. It's a,
I want to participate.
I understand that. Um,
but I don't think Michael Mouse
votes doesn't, he does it.
Didn't he say he doesn't vote?
I think he said he doesn't,
I forget his reasoning, but it was very
logical. No, I understand the argument,
but I even, and even if it
seems kind of false and I just,
I think it kind of like mentally
engages you in the world.
It's like you should be
trying to participate.
I think his perspective is that
as a commentator on the world,
that'd be better off if he didn't
actually vote and just look at it how he
really sees it on both
sides. Right? Partial.
Yeah. I'm sure I'm butchering
the way he would phrase it.
Think it's in the spirit of that.
If you vote,
you don't have a right to complain.
All right. Okay. That doesn't even
make sense. That doesn't make anything
that was deep. Well, but I think,
uh, but look, it's, it's a lot.
Look,
I think it's trying to be a good person.
I'm just a person level and try and take
care of your family and work hard and
be good with people and
help your community.
That's kind of the extent of what you
can do. And hopefully that spreads out.
But you know, Julian Assan. Okay,
whoa. Really? I mean, why
is that, you know? Well,
like all those people that we're talking
about at that generation that only got
news during that six o'clock
hour, you know, were they less
citizens of the world because they only
got that little dose, I don't know.
They were less
formed.
And the idea is that more people can get
away with things they shouldn't be able
to get away with. Like what's happening
right now with Julian Assange,
Julian Assange in anybody's estimation,
if you look at what he did,
he distributed information
that was extremely interesting
to most people in the
world that didn't know about it.
Right. Exposed a lot of scary shit.
Yeah. He's supposed a lot of corruption
as opposed a lot of, um, I mean, what,
what corruption did it expose? I know
it exposed the, there was that, um,
was it a collateral murder video?
That was the f one of the first ones
where they showed them shooting.
They shot at,
um,
these guys where they thought
were soldiers and they
were, they were reporters.
And it was just sort of just
the way they dealt with it.
It was very scary for people watching
that someone could just like dehumanize
accidentally killing the wrong people.
I make it like the military,
they were the Megan at
like, you know, hey,
but you kind of have to be in that
mindset to be able to gun people down from
the sky in the first place.
The whole look,
you gotta put yourself in the perspective
of someone who has to do that job and
you take a regular person and then you
train them to do that job and then you
ask them to go and pull
the trigger and people,
they're going to develop a coldness
to them. Yeah, they have to. Right.
But to see it,
so with Julian Assange did is he showed
it to us and then he released all sorts
of, I mean, I, I've, I haven't,
I'm embarrassed to say that I haven't
really studied all the files and what was
released and what wasn't apparently
was when Ben Shapiro was here.
He said that, uh, people's
names got a put out.
Apparently that was someone hacked into
wikileaks and release that information
before they could redact the names.
This was the,
this is what I've been told by multiple
sources. But again, I didn't look into it.
I don't know if that was correct.
So they're going to say that he
was treasonous or that he was,
I don't know what they're going to say.
I think the first thing was a sex charge.
That's what they were trying to say.
That he had sex with a woman. Um,
they wear shoes,
he wore a condom and then they had sex
and then they had sex in the morning with
no condom and she didn't consent to that,
that he just kinda did it or something.
I think it was something along,
I think they called it Soprise sex and
if I'm butchering this, I'm sorry. Um,
but the,
um,
that didn't make sense like that there
would be going after him that way.
Obviously. Not about that. Yeah.
You go after if you want to get
somebody to go after him for whatever.
I think there's kind of like hacking
charges now, right? Yeah. I don't know.
I know he's a little crazy in
the, in the embassy, right. He,
he wouldn't clean up after his cat
and he was riding a scooter around.
Is that true? That's what I don't
know. Who knows what's true.
I know that's part of the problem,
but that's what's part of the
little story that I caught.
The Little Duncan was
poetically describing what
the embassy must have smelled
like dirty cat shit
wafting through the halls. Yeah. Crazy
asshole. Do you have staying here?
Won't leave.
Pamela Anderson comes over every now
and then they get their free con,
the surveillance footage of Julian Assan
skateboarding in the Ecuadorian embassy
in London has been leaked. Okay.
Yeah, but here's the thing man.
Like what do you want the guy to do?
Is there a problem?
He's there for seven fucking years
now. He must have gotten crazy. I mean,
that's like being, you know,
under house arrest dude.
I mean it's amazing that he lasted
that long and what they did,
they waited them out and then when it
there, we're never going to wait him out.
He was gonna stay in there forever.
And then I guess got sick of him.
They just get sick of him. I think
it was also the Ecuadorian president.
I think he took a
photograph in front of a,
like some lobsters and shit and it was
from a leaked email in that photo got out
and it was very embarrassing to him
because his country's in deep financial
crisis and he's chilling in some
foresees and somewhere he loves tearing
lobster. Yeah, well I
don't know. I mean, look,
it's funny that when you
see pictures of Trump,
he's eating Kentucky Fried Chicken. When
you see pictures of this dude, he's,
he loves her and Trump phrase Kentucky
fried chicken was fucking private jet
hilarious. He really loves that stuff.
He really, he fucking loves fast food.
Like when he got all those athletes,
when they came to visit him and the
government was shut down and brought them
all fast food, he didn't understand
it. Like what the fuck this shit.
And then he had another team showed up
months later and he broke out the fast
food again. The government was
hope. Just imagine the fucking,
you're going to see the president
of the United States and you are a
professional athlete. Yeah, right.
Your body literally is a temple and
they were college athletes, but oh,
they're college. I would still
listen. Let's be real about that. Huh?
How much athletes should get fucking paid?
Crazy.
That's the biggest robbery and all of
that bled ex college sports to get into
the NBA and the NFL,
but you're making billions off these kids.
Fucking billions. Don't give
them a swell. Much money,
$20 fucking fast food.
I'm telling you,
man, this guy, in terms
of like material current,
it's almost like we glutton doubt.
It's almost like Trump was ice
cream like when he was in office.
He was so good for comedy that it looks
like there are so many Trump jokes now.
Everyone's like, no mom anymore.
I can't take another bite. He's, I need
something else. I can't have ice cream.
These are one more bite ice creams going
to come check it out of your throat.
It's really true. It's so,
he's so fucking eccentric,
like good or bad.
Just look at him as a human.
It's such a rare human. Yeah. You
know, I mean you've seen it with the,
with the hair and the constant golfing.
Even though he shit,
he shit on fucking Obama Golfing
and he's got way more than him.
He doesn't even try to pretend
these about a hypocrite. No,
he's just everything.
He's just the fat American on a jet Ski.
Just letting it rip.
Curious if you know what's also hilarious.
I think this is a real thing. Trump
derangement syndrome. I think it's real,
but you mean people that are obsessed
with him and they're obsessed with,
you know, this is the thing
that's going to get them.
He'll be out of office in three weeks
instead of like looking at it like this is
the argument for a guy like Michael
Mouse that he's an objective analyst.
Stepping back, looking
at this, he's doesn't,
he doesn't have a vested interest in this
guy winning or that Cayenne and when,
and he's just going, hmm, what is this?
Sitting back and watching this is
if I'm going to take that position,
not emotionally involved because some
people get so emotionally involved they
can't sleep, they start crying, they
think it's the end of the world.
The world is exactly the same.
We just have a different figure head
and I think it would present challenges
that will make us more
understanding of each other do.
That's what I really think.
I think there's,
there's good and bad
about every situation,
but the pro I see is communication.
If we're just honest with
the way we communicate,
I think people on the right and people
on the left, they share a lot in common.
There's a lot, a lot that
they share rather than what
they don't share in common.
The only thing they don't share is what
they're watching. How others. Right.
And then also the vibe you get like this,
the vibe from these,
whatever, whether it's CNN, whatever
show you're into, MSNBC, Fox News,
they all give out a vibe and that
vibe is, you know, we are right.
Here's what's going on. Here's
why that's a problem. You know,
and everyone has a different problem and
everyone thinks they're right and then
you have, so you have
different things. You,
some of them are have like eagles
and flags and Tom Fox News.
Yeah. I'm into that kind of truth.
Gimme gimme that shit. Yeah. Fucking,
yeah. Yeah. Come over here
the right way. All right guys.
Yeah. Yeah. Fucking neighbor.
Let him over to you a fucking day,
bud.
Rachel Maddow trucks and hats and
guns and so that becomes your team.
That becomes your claim.
That's what it is. It's the
team thing. Most of it and it,
and the,
the unfortunate part is both are saying,
are spending so much time rather than
thinking about this is the problem that we
have to deal with.
They're spending all their time thinking
those other people are assholes. Right,
exactly. It's being, it's the,
the venomous attacks against a fellow
Americans because they have a slightly
different view about healthcare.
That part is the,
the derangement of the culture right now.
They're not enemies. They're Americans.
You know, we're all on team
America. Exactly. Greta,
this fucking thing in that, bro.
Exactly. Those were all together,
which I sat the bench.
It is a wild country when you travel
around and look at my phone, watch this.
Then you got the flag
blowing in the wind, bro.
It moves.
I believe in America is a concept.
I don't think it's a bad thing to believe
in America as a concept where we're
getting better. We're,
we're working on this.
I think this idea that the people were
complaining that someone put the American
flag on a cop car and
a California that shit.
Yeah. Like, Hey, this
is, we're in America.
What do you mean they put us
rod back and flag on a cop car?
Like just draped it over it.
No,
like they had like the side panel where
it says the police department has the
American flag incorporated into their
logo. Like what do you hate America?
What's wrong with that? I like
it. Yeah. It's pretty like it.
I fucking salute those cars as they
drove by on a beach. Yeah. Problem.
Who doesn't like the American flag?
What's wrong with being a patriot?
It's imperialism, man.
Everything. It's all the good too.
It's all the creativity. All the art,
all the love, all the positive people,
all the opportunity people. It's
amazing. We're one country. Look at this.
Oh my God,
let's see this fucking quote.
We have such an amazing community of
artists here and I thought the aesthetic
didn't really represent our community.
This person said it feels very aggressive.
Bitch.
You're in the winters team, right? Okay.
You were in Laguna biatch aggressive
and artists and Laguna beach.
Just loving life. Marguerite is
everyday at four it's aggressive.
That's why you can walk around
with flip flops. You fucking idiot.
It's aggressive.
It's not aggressive to you.
It's not aggressive policing your friends,
the whole,
if something happens to your house,
who do you want to come near?
This water is water
color kit or the police,
but then not even saying that like
the police car, the colors on the car.
They're not saying we shouldn't have
police saying that flag is too aggressive.
It's the flag and the police
like that is the flag.
Make it more aggressive. That
is so stupid. I don't get it,
but it's that thought process.
It's just something wrong with us.
Well there is that there is that knee
jerk reaction from people on the far left.
The thing, everything
we do is evil. You know,
from the beginning of the country to now
we're just corrupt and evil and awful
than why you still here now.
Why are you going to the arcade?
They would all admit that it has great
qualities of problems is the problem is
when people really focus on
only the negative aspects,
the negative aspects of this country
are real. They're real, of course,
some top to bottom in every,
in every,
in every group of human beings
and negative aspects are real.
But this group of human beings in a
relatively short period of time has this
group of human beings has managed to
accomplish insane architecture, music,
comedy,
writing
it and dominate the world.
I mean it's a crazy fucking weird place,
but you dominate the world
in a democratic sense, right?
With with a democratic election
in the, in their country, ladies,
mostly peaceful manner.
The real problem was,
and then you start wondering like what
the United States does outside of this
country and whether or not they
should be doing it. Right. It's like,
are they doing this because they have
to do this because this is the way the
rules work in that country or I mean,
why are they propping up this guy
when this guy is clearly a dictator?
Is it better to have the dictator in
charge and have it become a failed state
like Libya, all the shit that's way
beyond our pay grade. Right, exactly.
It gets screwy. You say
like, yeah, I don't like what
America does overseas. Okay.
I don't exactly know what they do and I
don't think you do either. No, exactly.
I think there's some, until Julius tells
us clearly, some people know, right?
Some people are super educated,
informed. I'm not, I'm not denying that,
but what I'm saying is that most of
the people that have these really
aggressive opinions about
these things, yeah, and look,
there's don't necessarily think they've
thought about it too deeply. No,
but you also know that, you know,
look, everybody knows the country.
Does some dirty stuff in
places that wasn't cool,
what funds your country
doesn't. You're right. Exactly.
Wait,
the thing things these militaries and
these countries have to do in order to
keep peace and
yeah, and, and, and you know,
you want to shine light on that,
so maybe it's not done
again, but it's, uh, it's,
it's part of the thing that we're
talking about before about like our
grandparents not having a lot of the
information in a way that you're living in
the dark and that's bad,
but in a way,
you're living in the light
now and you see everything.
The problem with seeing everything,
I think it kind of is a problem is
that you realize that no organization,
no country,
no government is flawless,
no person, they're flawed.
Everything is flawed, everything.
And now we have this idea that
if somebody isn't perfect,
they should be just run out of
town. Cancel. Yeah. Canceled,
kicked out of office, whatever.
Yup. We're all flawed.
Everybody's flawed. And this idea,
because we can find everything else out,
you can expose everyone's flaws.
What we're going to have to come out
of this somehow realizing that flawed
doesn't mean that they're evil or they're
negative and they have to be kicked
out. Do you think there's ever
going to be a time in, in humans,
like whether it's a hundred years from
now or a thousand years now where there's
no war?
Yes,
yes I do.
How do you see that happening? Well,
it's going to start with cop cars,
with flags on them
and then they're going to put stroller.
I think it would be technology and I
think it's a matter of everybody becoming
more comfortable if you can,
if you can have people,
this is like a Thomas
Friedman idea that if,
if you want to stop like people
fighting in the Middle East, uh,
give them all the comforts
of a good society,
let them be able to go eat McDonald's
and sit in a coffee shop and all of a
sudden you don't want to fight as much.
And that means prosperity.
That means popping.
So I think technology,
if you can bring more water to
people and there's less suffering,
if climate change doesn't
turn ruin all of that.
I think if you can prop these people up
and give all these people if they can
rise and there's no sense.
I mean we're in a point now where there's
fewer wars than ever before on the
planet. Sure. So we're headed in that
direction. So I don't see why not.
Well, as a thought exercise,
let's look at it this way.
What makes anybody
decide to act as a group?
What makes anybody like if
why would we decide to go?
Right? What negotiations should we
be having with someone in Germany?
Like why,
why,
why are we having a conversation about
anything you live way the fuck over there
on the other side of the ocean.
What would make people act as a group
and go over and try to fuck with somebody
else that's, that's in another
place like, well, people can be,
people can definitely be rallied.
All right. For any cause.
Most certainly.
But do you think this is my thought that
there will come a time where that kind
of rallying doesn't work,
that people will stop believing?
I mean this is one of those very bizarre
ideas that the systems that we've
established for, for human civilizations,
whether it's countries or cities or um,
uh, continents, right?
Whatever it is, these systems,
once all the boundaries that kept
people from freely traveling, all the,
once those are, those all broken down,
no country anymore and they keeping this,
keeping it together now is
the fact that it's air travel.
So they know when you're coming in
and they get to check your papers,
you're flying in from overseas,
are you Mister Papa was only one way.
Motherfucker,
you got to land right here in this spot.
And then we take each individual and
we say, can I see your paperwork?
What do you got? Who are you, where
are you from? Where were you born?
Do you have money or you're a drug addict.
You have been arrested.
And then they're allowed. They could still
do that that way. If that didn't exist,
if it was way easier to go to Germany,
there was a technology
that would allow you,
like a person like you or made the
same way we could drive places.
We could just fly into
somewhere and land anywhere.
You don't have to go to a fucking
specific location like an airport or get
funneled through a road that takes you to
some, you know, some checkpoint station,
like when you're trying to drive from
Mexico. Just if people could fly. Yeah.
If people, if people flew anywhere they
wanted to go, if that technology existed,
good fucking luck keeping people from
coming into your city. Good luck.
All those rules are out the window,
but it does all those immigration rules
that doesn't exist anymore. Can't exist.
People can go anywhere.
Right? But what are you saying
that gives you, well, the gives you
the interaction with
human beings like you.
You won't be able to get them as a group
as easily to go after another group.
Right. Because now there's
no country basically. There's
no like thing to, right.
We're not part of this that has to
go fight that. Right. We're all in.
We're all one now here's the do have one
person lives in a great spot and they
don't want to give up their oil, right?
Right. Then it becomes a problem, right?
Come on, resources. We're all in this
together. Those people in Alaska,
you know they got all that
fucking oil, bro. Here's how.
Here's two things though. Here's two
things of why it might not work. One,
still this college, but I only
two that I can think of. Okay,
let me hear a one.
Italians are Italians and Germans are
Germans and Mexicans are Mexicans and you
get around your people and you feel it
and you know it and I know who you are
and we're part of that tribe and we're
part of that thing and it doesn't matter
that we grew up somewhere.
I just know you as an Italian and
I'm an Italian and I am with you,
and that is very different from that
Turkish guy over there. That thing,
that very human thing,
chemistry thing of your own blood,
your own thing. I don't think
that's going to go away for Bro.
You're old school and you bake bread.
I didn't, you're talking nonsense.
It's truly things. You're the old
timey thing. I do love all the time.
He thinks your eyes without glasses.
You'd be like, Nah, I liked the class.
I put him on and get ready to go to work.
But I think that's a real thing.
Horse cars and your friend,
your friend, you give him, Hey,
this shit is actually
really good for fertilizer.
All right,
well I'm going to blow your mind with
my technology in this conversation,
which I just read an article
yesterday that in uh,
China face recognition is the thing
that's going to stop your fantasy of
everybody just loving each other and
going around in China there with face
recognition,
they're able to recognize and
categorize Muslims in the country.
There's like this one sect of Muslim
in China and they're with all this face
recognition that they're seeing, you
know, from your phone, from everything.
They're starting to catalog
the enemy and they're,
and they're going to be able to police
or sharing information and hotels and
everybody and they're all
now through this network. No.
What type of person just walked into this
building and whether they're friendly
or they're the enemy and that thing,
that face recognition thing is PR could
end up splitting us apart even more old
timey.
Tommy with his technological facts.
China's big brother
surveillance technology isn't
nearly as all seeing as the
government wants you to think.
This is kind of like a,
they might be able to upgrade it
though. It says it can't for sure. Yeah.
That's one point.
Oh,
when your phone unlocked
with your fingerprint and
it blew your mother fucking
money, you're like, Bro,
it's really, it's my finger,
pinky and even worse, my pinkie five
fingerprints on this motherfucker.
It'd be give consent as I could to do
the side of my thumb and it's still knows
his glasses. What do you
mean with that? As a cop?
It's a cop with Google last year. It's
got some sort of face recognition thing.
It's like that time grows that
Tom Cruise movie minority report.
What was that real?
Yeah.
Not Tom Cruise is definitely there.
I don't know,
but that's, you know, I try to
Google glass on once I actually, oh,
through a whole UFC Wayans wearing the
Google glass. How was it filming it,
I guess? Um, ah, it wasn't ready.
It wasn't ready and I think that's
why they haven't upgraded it.
Let's hold off because this is
not working. It's been a while.
It's not new to that Dorky Shit.
And people got super uncomfortable
when you around them.
It's like holy a camera on everybody
walking around with a fucking camera
everywhere.
I think they'll have something eventually,
but I have a feeling it'll be
something where there's a technology.
What were the outside you,
you can't see things when the inside
you can and then they'll show you images
like directly in front of you on the Lens.
So like you wear glasses,
like your glasses, but it'll show
you things right in front of you.
Yeah.
I got one that I heard that I don't know
if I understand and believe that this
is real,
but I just googled it and I
found something that makes
it seem like it's so the
next version of the VR
headsets are supposed to have
brain tracking in them and
that sounds super, but it's already
being implemented and tested.
You get a knock on your door.
Are you thinking about as beaten off?
What is wrong with you,
man? No, no, no. We,
we thought you were a regular person,
but you're beating off a
hundred times a week. Yeah.
You imagine if they wanted to
have a talk to you like Mr Papa,
you watched 14 hours of pornography
this week. Yeah. That seems a lot. Yeah.
I think your mother would think
that. It seems like, I mean,
I don't want to talk to her.
Say employers are going to do that.
Insurance companies are going to do that
and they're going to be able to hold
much. You're beating on how much you're
beaten off, how much you're working out,
how much you're sleeping,
whether and what.
Look at that to share only good stuff.
That's like Google when they
said don't be evil. Abandon that.
Once you started making money, they
fucking paint it right over that side.
Maybe a little evil. What is evil,
man? I mean, what is evil, evil?
Schmiegel we're going in
that direction. Yeah, man.
It's going in that direction and it's all
going to some sort of a wearable thing
that connects you, but a weird thing
that like everywhere you're going there,
picking off your face and then
you're going to be able to,
they're going to know exactly what
you are and who you are. Yeah. No,
it's a strange, it's strange. Uh, but it,
is it any more strange than our lives
today in comparison to people that lived
in 1920 like we were talking about
earlier. This is way weirder. Weightless,
super weird way weirder wearing
weird town already for sure.
You just hope it doesn't get into the
hands of people that can really mess with
you. Oh yeah. The people with the money
put the money and all the control,
they are going to be cool with
it. Right? Yeah, that'd be great.
There'll be all right. Yeah, that'd
be fine. Everything's gonna be fine.
Do you have a Alexa in your
house? Yeah, my kids do.
My from my one friend is
always trying to tell me,
just get that out of your house.
It's listening to everything that you
say and everything that you can do about
it in that room.
I had a question about that.
You know, neuro link might be
coming on soon or whatever.
I was thinking about like if,
if it got to the point where like say
we all got it and then everyone you knew
had it and there's like a thousand
people that have it when it hit like a
threshold point where you're like, ah,
not everybody should have this. We're,
we're good at this point right here.
How would you ever deny people
something like that? The cost,
they might be really expensive to know.
How would you ever,
I know you can't deny people that won't
like say if someone's coming up and they
want to try it and everyone else has it,
that would,
that would create a giant problem.
That'd be like if you said
that with cell phones,
too many people have cell phones. We have
to stop you no more buying cell phones.
I know.
That's why I sort of think like that.
There might become a big problem
with that. Why? What is darling?
But hold on a second.
I don't understand why you think,
I just sort of think that if, uh, in
the theory that you're going to let it,
thousands of people have instant access
to the world's knowledge at their
fingertips, at a, at a
thoughts like instant,
that becomes too powerful in the wrong
hands and the people that might have at
first might see the, the future problems
of that. I'm just, what I was wondering,
I was thinking way too
far. Jamie got high. Yeah.
That sounds like you got high and watch
superman. She answer. You say it was like,
no, that probably won't be a problem
or, well, no, I, I can't stop it though.
I don't sort.
I'm wondering,
I don't think that anyone can say
that's not going to be a problem. Yeah.
I don't know. I mean, what is a problem
though? It's going to be something.
It's going to be a something.
Yeah, it's going to change.
One has access to all the world's
information instantaneously. First of all,
colleges are going under sun.
That was my first thought was
like they're going to fight.
That happened fast and that all day
until I think they can. But yeah,
I just have to be able to,
the amount of money that you would make
off of something that made everybody
super smart. Yeah. There's no way
you can imagine if you found out,
how ironic would it be if you found
out that like Stanford and Harvard are
banded together to try to stop this from
coming out cause it would kill their
business
guys together and it was like,
you know,
just like how college admission
scandals going down so great.
There was a scandal that all these higher
universities had banded together to
try to stop this cause he was
going to kill the business.
Everybody can know everything.
We tell them more than everything we
tell them I'm going on some college tours
already. Jesus Christ. Oh my God,
I really makes you think. I'm like,
what did I do? They really need this.
This is expensive. Oh, do they
really need a a degree in all of
this? I don't know. It's a weird
businessman. It's a total weird business.
Don't know why it costs so
much. I'll tell you why. Why?
Because the administrators are all
making bank. Is that what it is? Yeah.
It's all the money that's going on.
So all these kids,
generations are in debt because they
have to take these student loans because
college is more expensive
than ever before. Well,
it hasn't changed running the
university lead the teachers,
it's the administration of these giant
universities are making so much money.
They're making millions and they
keep cranking it out and they keep,
keep needing to up the up the rate and
then they make money accessible for the
students through loans and then they
keep feeding themselves. It's horrible.
It's a horrible corrupt system. And
it's um, it's also subsidized rent.
Well, the government will
subsidize something. Yeah. Yeah.
How much does the government subsidize
private education? Private education.
That's, I don't think Hannah. Yeah.
Yeah. You got fast. Full on now. Yeah.
It's so expensive. I mean, you
know, isn't that weird too,
there's like state schools, private
schools. Yes. They all cost money.
Everything costs money. Yeah. Like
what is it like to get to like USC?
How much is like a semester at
USC? 70,000 no, not as a master.
A year. A year. Is it 70,000
roughly 70 50 for the year.
Yeah. That's like the, that's the,
that's the online Google search thing.
That's 50 plus room and board plus all
the rest of them. If your kid fucks off,
yes. Which of course they're going to
do. And by the way, to have 50 grand,
you need to make like 80 right.
Or taxes you to be,
how to make 80 grand. Yeah. For a whole
year of your kid being in school. Yeah.
And if your kid's just
doing bongheads totally.
My father dropped me off to school
at school and I was like a sophomore.
It just drove me into,
into college and drop off my stuff and I
was so psyched to go see my friends and
just kind of, you know, just work hard.
Be Responsible. Okay. Dad. Okay. Okay.
I go running into my, uh, dorm
room. My buddies are there.
I haven't seen them all break
Tom. They hand me a bong. Hey,
I light up. As soon as I walk in,
buy bags or haven't even trap,
I light it with my lighter and this huge
flame comes out and almost like lights
my fire. I'm like, why? Blah, blah, blah.
Hey Papa, your dad's outside. He's
in the van. I had forgot something.
I forgot a lamp in the van. I
go running out there. I'm like,
Hey, what's up? You know, hope and I don't
smell. He goes, hey, you forgot your,
what happened to your eyebrow?
Your eyebrows burnt off.
What did you do in the two minutes?
I just took the lamp. Thanks Dad
checks. He's writing checks for me
to go and do. Yeah, it's brutal.
Jesus. Actually more that
was just tuition. I saw,
I see 75 $75,000 USC one year room and
boards 15 three that's got to be low
because that's just about it.
Over a thousand a month.
It's kind of be a man and
that's without like if your kid,
if you live on the east coast and you're
flying your kid back and forth and all
the rest of it, look at personal
expense, personal and miscellaneous,
1400 bucks for the year for the hundred
bucks a month. Get Out. That's crazy.
Yet it, forget it. The books,
they're going to be way
more than a hundred bucks a
month to the books are going
to be 1200 a semester. Probably.
You should go to state school.
You pay a quarter of that.
Stay in, get your undergrad.
Things like you could have a
nonsense education like me.
Well you just read things that you're
interested in and then you never get like
a real base education.
I don't have a degree in anything.
He didn't go to college. I went
to college, but I fucked off.
I barely paid attention. I
went to Umass Boston, so yeah,
that's when my sister went. I didn't
even take my sats. No, really? No.
There was like a,
they had like a continuing education
program and you just sign up and start
taking classes there. Oh Nice.
Did you go the whole way? No,
I went for three years.
I was barely paying attention
three years I did it.
I guess I realized I was doing it a little
bit while it was still doing standup,
like while I started doing
stand up. Uh, it was,
it was literally only so that people
didn't think I was a loser. Right.
I just wanted to let people know I'm
doing something I didn't pay attention at
all. Right. I will.
All I was thinking about was a martial
arts competition and then it was stand up.
Well, yeah, the transition right there.
Yeah. Once that happens, forget it.
And once I realized that people made
money doing standup, that's when I quit.
It depends on what you want to go do.
Like there's certain you want to go in
law or you want to do certain, you know,
Madison, there's certain
routes where you need a degree.
We really need a degree and
there's definitely something
good to going to school
and being around other people from around
the country and all kind of thinking
for sure. It's all positive,
but you should not go into debt.
I have all these nephews
that they got out of school,
$30,000 in debt. Right? This is
the start of your life as an adult.
The worst 30,000 in debt.
They can't keep up with the payments so
that and the interest kicks in and after
four years,
now they owe 50,000 and they're constantly
chasing it and now they ask their
parents to help them out and they co
sign now you have two generations and
they've got to pay taxes. Right. And,
and they're now on their second
job where no one cares anymore.
Where you went to school, they never even
asked the question. They don't know. Not,
not an s now. No. In certain
places. Yeah. In certain routes.
Really depends on what you're trying to
do. Right? You've got to be a doctor.
Think they care.
Yes.
I think they care. Oh yeah. Well
maybe it depends what kind of doctor.
There's a lot of that. Just a professor
you probably applying for jobs,
a history professor. I went to
television production, whatever,
and no one gives a shit.
Well that's true.
If you're going to do Hollywood type
jobs. Yeah. Nobody gives a fuck. No.
Go working in construction.
You can do what
my whole thing is, and I keep
trying to say this is my daughter,
is that you should never don't
jeopardize your future for this degree.
You can get degrees, there'll
be important. They'll help you,
but you should not strap yourself with
debt. That's why the advice. Yeah,
very wise advice and she's like,
how about you work harder and just pay
for it and I won't have to be in debt.
That's a good thing for her
to say. Yeah, it's clever.
Very smart to set you up
and my other daughter,
I'm just going to give her head shots.
$300 a head shots right in the business.
The business done that old show business.
Hey,
everybody's crazy. But I thought
showbiz people crazy. Everyone's crazy.
Every girl crazy. I'm crazy. Yeah.
The people who you think insurance
salesmen, people are fucking crazy.
They just better at hiding it all day.
Yeah. That's what they're doing. They,
that's what they do. They hide
it. They hide it all fucking day.
If you were really smart, he'd
just go into plumbing. Listen,
there's not a lot of plumbers
out there need plumbing. Yeah.
And you make a really good living at it
and there's not a lot of people that are
learning these skills anymore.
That's what you should go do or do
something you really want to do.
Find something you really want to do.
Yeah.
Maybe you don't want to
be a plumber should be a
requirement that they know what
they want to do before
they go into college now.
But to see what college
should be is education would,
it really seems to be more,
it's like prepping you for the job for us.
You know what I mean?
There's education as well,
but it's prepping you for the job force
and nowadays at least in a certain
segment of the population,
you're,
you're getting these colleges that are
also like socially indoctrinating kids,
socialist ideas and a lot
of ideas that you know,
just are contrary to what probably
their parents taught them.
So then there's this internal dispute
and who's right and who's wrong and do I
rebel against my parents? Both
full social justice warrior. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Join the young Republicans on campus and
the El kids are just trying to find who
they are. Yeah, there's definitely
when you walk onto these campuses,
even just to tour them,
which I never did when I was,
I just picked one out and went,
but you go in the personality of
each university is so dominant.
As soon as you walk onto the
campus and went to some small, uh,
really left liberal arts schools and
you just feel like the posters and
everything, you're just like as a, as a
white male, you're not welcoming at all.
And then you go to some other places
and it's just kind of free flowing and
everybody's just, it's into this,
they're just all about the football team.
Have you ever seen a poster? It says I
as a white male, you're not welcome here.
Yeah.
Where in my daughter's room.
That's hilarious. No, but you
know, you like, it's like very,
very progressive and
very, you know, every,
everything is an issue and that's
where you develop those ideas.
But what I'm saying is you can really
learn from going on these campuses like,
oh, this is, well, there's a
vibe. You get indoctrinated,
indoctrinated into whatever
vibe the campus holds.
You get social points for like following
those ideas as hardcore as you can.
It's ready. It's really interesting. Yeah.
If you take yourself out of whichever way
you lean, if you lean left, you can say,
well, it's because they're
young and they're passionate
and they're right. Right.
He'll lean right like God,
they're babies and they're being taught
by people who never made it in the real
world. The only just
in academia and, yeah,
but just look at instead
of looking at it like that,
look at it where you don't have a fucking
dog in the fight and just step back
and go,
this is fascinating.
It's like people are just
trying to change an influence,
people's thinking and behavior and
some of it is to justify their,
their own thinking and behavior.
Some of it is because some people
just like controlling people,
like getting people to listen to them,
and some of it is because they genuinely
think that this is for the best for the
human race and it's all these
things are competing together.
That's why you have some people that
are activists and you meet them.
They're not annoying at
all. You're like, God damn,
you were really cool because they're doing
it with the right heart, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
Of activists that are so annoying,
so annoying because they're not
doing it for the right reasons.
They're nailing it to try to change
people because they want to poke you.
They want to,
they want to have a reason to be upset
at you because you're not listening to
them. You're not following their ideas,
them and there. Those are the key words.
It's about them, them and their status
and their power over you and yeah. No,
I know there's a couple of people,
you know,
there's a couple of people I know that
have gotten that way so hard that you
can't even have conversations with
them on both sides. It doesn't help.
It doesn't, all it does is
create more, more conflict.
Like that can of combative
attitude creates more conflict.
You can be right on every single issue.
What if you're super,
super combative all the
time that people just don't,
they don't want to communicate with you
and they're now willing to enter into an
honest exchange with you.
Cause it's always a contest.
There's a battle going on,
right? And you always think you're
right, right? It's US versus the,
and they're just looking for little
clues and see where you're at.
And if you give them any kind of
hint that you might lean one way,
they just pounce on you and it's brutal.
It's like this,
it's a horrible way to live. And
they're angry. They're just angry.
They just walk around with his anger.
It's like get an ice cream cone.
Enjoy your life a little bit.
Like what are your core Dodgers fans?
That's what they are core sports fans for.
The Democrats,
like our fucking team's going to kick
their fucking ass in 2020 Trump's going
down. Right, exactly. It's really
bad. It really is that, hey,
did you see tiger yesterday? Today? I
was watching it while we were in Georgia.
We were in Georgia for the UFC and I had
a comedy show out there and we were me
and um, Santino or watching
it on the screen. Uh,
on Saturday or yesterday. We watched
it Friday or was it Friday or Saturday?
Saturday. So Friday, Saturday
in anyone yesterday. Well,
whatever days it was, right.
I think we watched it two days in a row.
It was in the gym every day we were there,
but then I got home and I saw it
on my phone. I was like, Holy Shit.
I don't even give a fuck about golf.
I know I'm going to speak powerful.
I made a comeback, a huge comeback
with that. I mean, that's amazing.
Seven years later,
oh my God,
somebody's put on Instagram.
One of my quotes. Oh yeah.
That I attached to that.
It was pretty cool that I
love a guy get like, I love,
what did I say? I love a success story,
but even more than that, I love a guy,
fucks his life up and then gets it back
together again. Story. It's the greatest,
it's the greatest.
When you realize how much of us good
it must feel to that guy of top of the
world again. And then he like, yeah,
it was so messed up in the back problems
and troubles and the kids and the wife
and the thing and he just 11 years.
Yup. And he didn't stop working.
He just went to work and went to work and
went to where he is it 11 years later.
And so he won major championship
recently. Right? Did anyone win one?
It was a big deal. He won a major
championship within the last,
it wasn't a manager, but it was, it wasn't
a major this, this was the first major.
He's one in 11 years. Okay. So
the other one wasn't a major,
but it was a big event. It
was a big tournament. He wins
that whenever I was like,
wow, he might be back. He can, he can
fucking win big tournament's again.
And then he just,
Oh,
it was so cool to see the crowd just
kept building over the weekend and by
yesterday it was massive.
Thousands of people around the
green just hanging on him. Oh,
the relief that you saw just
coming out of him was so great.
And then at the end like he walks off
where as a kid he was only like 21 when he
went in the first time
hugging his dad at the edge.
And now he comes off 11
years later all this time.
And His dad's passed and
he's hugging his child,
his son now he's the father
in the same spot. Oh,
it was just, I was trying not
to cry the whole time. Oh,
it was such a tear jerker what relief.
People were just so happy for
him. Wow. Such a great story.
We do love a comeback to why not
man, you love a comeback. We,
we're all flawed like you
were saying before. But yeah,
man, being able to improve.
That's what that guy did. He sit
down and in pre improved. Amazing.
Improved his life. Yeah.
And never stopped. Yeah.
It went south and he picked it right
back up. Brought it north again. Yeah.
11 years of doing it and failing,
failing and failing.
Is that beautiful? It is
beautiful. Such a cool thing. Yeah.
I was wondering like he wears that red
shirt, he's got to wear the red on Sunday.
It's like his, that's his
thing. That's his thing.
And he was in the light colors
on a Saturday and I was like,
does he just like free himself from that
or is that a superstition that you got
to kind of hang on to? Good
question. Yeah. You know,
what do you think would happen if there
was an openly gay black guy with blonde
hair who only wore pink,
who was like the best golfer a lot.
It started dominating some dude who's
like super duper gangs and he's just got
this fucking crazy drive and,
and he gets down on the ground.
He could see the way the, the earth is
rolling and the whole time he's doing,
he's like lists bit snapping, his fingers
wiggling and, but you know, I pop pretty,
what would happen if he
started just winning? They
would probably poisoned them.
You think they would poison him
like a super flamboyant gay guy who
was willing. Okay. Black or white,
they would poison them.
So what do you don't think so?
I don't think so because golfers are so
close to flamboyantly queeny gay. Anyway,
look at their outfits. They're all pink
and like, Oh my God. Big Plaid pants.
They're like a bunch of old white dudes,
straight white dudes who want to be gay.
But it's all this country club life.
Right? The big part of it. Yeah,
but she had to have that guy swishing
around back and forth in the locker room.
Snapping his fingers.
Staring at Dicks. No, no, no,
no.
They're going to,
he's putting,
he's gotta,
he's gotta catch phrase hair
shaved except for a curly manbun.
It just pop straight up and it's blonde
and he wears lipstick and
he's a motherfucker at golf.
He's just killing fools.
Does love my irons.
Maybe it would maybe would open golf up
to everybody else. Yeah. What happened?
Like do you think that tiger woods,
tiger woods,
he opened up golf for people of Color,
right?
Clearly we got into it because of and
how many, how many people got into golf.
There would've never even thought about
playing golf. For sure. Tiger could play.
Started opening up to inner city schools.
We're starting to get involved in it.
What about the gay community?
Are they represented in professional golf?
Flamboyant dress like the BGS
and the 70s they're close, Joe.
They're wearing plaid pants. They're
wearing, they're wearing tassels.
You xenophobia.
That's how people from Scotland Trust
saying, I was just saying they would,
they would be embraced. You know,
Scotland's a weird place.
Like you have to dress a certain way when
you hunt there or at least they have a
certain way. They dress like a
traditional way. I like that,
but it's not like they don't wear
Cammo. It's like an outfit. Yeah.
It's like an outfit. Like what are
they were they were like close,
weird old timey clothes. I like that. I
like tradition. Um, yeah, I know you did.
That's why I brought it up.
Bordain went hunting in
Scotland who's television show,
right? He had to wear some
crazy ass outfit. Right.
You get suited for this outfit.
That's traditional hunting outfit.
It's pretty cool. A lot of those, but
it's, it's, it's, it's true. Chicago.
Those places like Scotland too.
If I'm in,
I think most of it was like private land.
Right.
I think back in the day like that was
what Robin Hood was all about. Right.
Robin Hood was originally supposed to
be about someone who was poaching and
hunting on the king's land because they
were hungry and so they were stealing
from the rich to feed the
poor gentlemanly pursuit,
hunting and shooting a tire. Wow.
How they dress. Does that help you?
Helps me be a good hunter cause aren't
get to goof on them or does it like does
that help? Does that get in the way
of hunting or is that help hunting,
but that's how I help and shit.
I'm tired of as a kind of fresh
though. Go back to his boots. Yeah man,
that guy looks at his boots.
Can you make them boots larger?
Look at those fresh boots.
I wear those on stage.
Would I get in trouble for cultural
appropriation wearing someone's stuff if
they're white too. I was at work and know
that if they're more powerful than you,
then you're okay. Like how does
that work? How does that work?
You can't take from how much,
what percentage of native American do you
have to have in you to wear moccasins?
Who a lot. The castle jacket. How about
the, like the Suede tasseled jacket?
I,
but they're like Roger
Daltrey rebels in the 70s war.
I wanted one of those so bad when I
was in high school. They look so cool.
The easy rider with the fringe
on it. It's all moving. Driving,
man. I wanted that arm out the window
of the car and it's flopping around.
You're on stage singing. The
ladies must love you. Oh,
Gloria [inaudible] strips a leather.
See you. But that goes too far.
See how it's because they have the
native American thing on the sleeve.
This one right here? No, not that
other one. Well that one. Yeah,
it's too far to that one.
If you do that one,
you better kill the bear that you used
for those fuckers. Yeah, that's too,
that's ridiculous. There's a white guy
version of that, which would be okay.
That's a girl claims to be a
healer. Yeah. That's where that,
see if you were that in Texas,
you're okay? Yeah. Okay.
Daniel Boone. Yeah, I'm here
with that one. That one's dark.
Dark one. Now what do you prince
and you're like, that guy.
What do you a trapper that's too light.
Bat looks terrible.
That guy looks terrible.
He's got the fringe of the bottom.
That's what's going to separate us from
else the curtain and on the bottom or
fringe. A Nice Kurt and then
a fine. A fine restaurant.
We'll get Elvis. Elvis had
tassels. Elvis had rainbow tassels.
You could get away with it
if you're Elvis, if you,
if you're working for enterprise,
rent a car,
I think you may be here.
You don't wear that.
Elvis got away with some wild shit.
Who the fuck we'll jumpsuits before Elvis
jumpsuits. It was him and evil Knievel.
Okay. Oh Man, look at that
Hendrix. Oh my God. That's,
yeah. See, but he's doing something. He's
playing the guitar, he's moving around.
He's got a headband. If you just, if
you're making snow cones, you don't,
that's not your jacket, man. I
wanted one when I was in high school.
I warm up a little bit. Never put that
back up. Put that picture back up.
Look at that. That look, how good
does it look and I could never wear,
he's got Fred Gianna yet.
What does that greenish yellow,
how would you describe that color? It's
like a teal, like a light teal light teal.
He's got, he's got bell bottoms, bell
bottom jeans, washed bell bottoms,
and he's got this cool jacket with fringes
that are literally two feet long and
then a headband to, and it's just his
kind of Fuchsia. The had been right.
It's kind of reddish, like a light
red and he's, it's on Jimi Hendrix.
That's the,
that's the thing that we can't match
when we could buy all those items,
but it's still our head.
Jimi Hendrix,
knowing that it's 2019 to back then,
like he was in the groove
man. Oh Man. He was the, yeah.
Phil Hartman saw him live when he was a
young kid. Phil was like 18 years old.
He got a job at the
whiskey and his job was,
you know how they have those giant
monitors on the stage and sometimes those
things would fall like into the crowd.
Who Cheats?
Like especially if someone's
standing on that are doing a show.
So they're kind of, they're a little
wobbly. So standing right there.
So his job was to stand
right by the stage,
like literally have his hands like
ready to catch these speakers.
This was Phil's job. Yes.
And Hendrix is right there.
Hendrick is right there
and he's 18 oh man.
Oh my God.
Right in front of them.
Let the thing just all seeing
the same Christ sign of them.
Geez Louise.
Kiss the sky.
I was that close to blues traveler once.
I don't think that's the same.
And this will his harmonica in his
past shortly before Jimi Hendrix died.
Oh really? Yeah. Oh well he died when he
was died in like he was the magic age.
Right? 35 was it? It's 20 everyone.
The Magic Age is 27 it's an all time or
Marsha anise. Isn't that the magic age?
Didn't he? Where did he 27.
Wow. Yeah. What year did he die?
Was it 69 70 70 1970. So Phil, you know,
that's amazing. I feel it was probably
like 17 years old or something like that.
God, fuck. That's amazing. Yeah.
Did he ever do one of those fringe
jackets? I don't know. I didn't ask that.
But the way you describe
it, man, it was way he
described. It was like running into Jesus
while you're out on a hike. Oh yeah.
It was crazy. Well, Phil was a musician
too, so when you know he talk about it.
We can,
I like this crazy clean too is hot cheese.
It was right fucking there. Right
there. Yeah. Come on. Don't,
don't Hendricks please.
I wanted a,
I wanted one of those fringe
jackets when I was in high school,
so I played football until I was a senior.
And then when once football season's over,
I have a half a year
left of school and uh,
that's when I smoked weed for the first
time and started playing guitar and I
want to win a fringe jackets.
I didn't have him,
but I did get a pair of moccasins
for a little while. I wore moccasins.
Did they have beads? They did not have
beads, but they had the little French,
a little tassels. They were like, it
was just a little fringe. Yeah. No soul.
What's the purpose of French like?
That's like when you think of a trapper
jacket, right? When I'm Dan Boone.
Davy Crockett type dudes style. Give
him wearing that style is really, yeah.
Why would they have any style back then?
Everybody's got style back then it
seems like they were just trying to stay
alive. Yeah, the weak ones,
but the cool ones are
still trying to get laid.
I think Daniel Boone wasn't
trying to work it a little bit.
Look at this.
Buck skins are often trimmed with a
fringe originally a functional detail to
allow the garment to shed rain
and to drive faster when wet.
Because the fringe acid, a series of
wix to disperse the water or quills.
Interesting.
Oh Wow.
Buckskins derived from hears can clothing
worn by native Americans. Oh Wow.
How about that? That's
genius. Smarter than you now.
So it hangs down and the
water goes through all the
tissue in the deer and gets
to the bottom. So those little things get
wet. But the thing that you're wearing,
the touches your skin is dry.
You would think by now that deer would
have had fringe on their outfits.
I think the don't give a fuck.
You're a really hot or that your body
temperature is much higher than ours. Oh,
really? That's one of the
weirder things about, um,
when you put your hands on one
inside of them, they're really hot.
Like if you're like 98 degrees, what
do they like? I don't know. I would,
if I had a cast, I'd say it's, it's more
than a hundred. I would say that. Yeah,
I bet they're probably like 105,
something like that. What is it?
What's the lot of temperature?
It brought up the cooking temperature.
350 degrees.
They're cooking before we even catch them.
It's hilarious.
That's why people love deer. You
don't have to cook them. Precooked
they're preheated same as most undulates,
which is 37.5 to 38.5 degrees Celsius,
which,
which we don't understand.
I'll just type in pre heated dear me.
38.5 degrees Celsius. What do you
think that is? If you had to guess,
I don't have a clue. What was the,
what was the number 38 degrees? Oh,
that's 105 is it?
No,
it's like 90 99.5 to a hundred.
Right.
In that same region like us one or to
hire someone with a little bit of fever.
Oh, I did something that you
would, you would enjoy. You
might have even done this.
Speaking of body heat, uh, I was
in San Francisco last weekend,
really performing and uh, I
was working with my friend, uh,
Kira Sultana Bitch, very
funny comedian. She kicks ass.
She's Russian.
She grew up up there and she brought me
to a Russian like bath house beat you
up. Sticks? Yeah. Did you ever do that?
They call it Banya Banya man.
Oh Man. You go into a sauna,
a two level sauna,
so it's even hotter like up at the top,
like an attic in a sauna,
super hot.
And you lay down on this bench
and they take these bushes,
he sticks and they were, they wet them
and then they start beating you with them.
Not a lot of pressure.
It's too, it's so hot. It,
you're in a sauna, you're already like,
really? Really. And then that thing,
that thing is hot too and that
thing's hot. And with the,
with the steam coming off of the branches,
as they're beating your back,
it creates a little,
a little pocket that gets even hotter.
So it just brings your body to this
super high temperature they're making and
making whether they really
are anyway and uh, yeah,
for about 15 minutes and you come out of
there and just feel to jump in the cold
afterwards. Yeah. Into a cold plunge all
the way under this really cold water.
Amazing. Yeah. The Russians really
let that fade or a million inco.
It was like a one of the
greatest heavyweights.
If not the greatest
heavyweight of all time.
One of the things that you'd
see about his training,
what does it was that it was
very old school. Russian,
like there's a lot of stuff on
the parking or in a, um, uh,
a playground just like they did a
lot of stuff on a playground and um,
he incorporated the Banjara that
was part of it and like he's,
you see him lying there and
they're beating him with
sticks. There you go. Yeah.
You don't show time. So there,
yeah, that's what, yeah,
they figured something out. You know,
all the pretty great invented sauna.
They figured something out.
There's something about that
extreme temperature that just, it,
it's very good for your, your ability
to recuperate. You feel better.
It reduces inflammation. I felt
great. Like I went in there,
I've been traveling so hard over the
last couple of months have just been
knotted up. I've just
been like, I was like,
maybe I'll do this and then get a
massage after. Cause that'll really,
the gentleman, he like a gentleman and
we didn't have time. She had to go.
She was driving me. She had
to go do something. So we
only had time for that part.
When I came out of the,
the, the Banya or Banya,
I didn't need a massage.
Everything was relaxed.
Everything had changed in just
like 15 minutes. It was great,
man. I wish it was a, I don't know if
there's, they have them in la or not,
but I'd like to seek
them out. They know they have them in New
York. One in West Hollywood. There is,
yeah. Voda spa or something like
that. Yeah. There you go bro.
A lot of dongs keep you bit pants with
a lot of dogs. Clothing was optional.
Hey, clothing optional. And
I'm with Kira, you know,
we're like coworkers and she's
wearing nothing. She's her.
She's totally naked. And then there's
dogs everywhere. There's dogs everywhere.
He's the dogs. She sees the
dogs. I see the downloads.
We were the only ones covered up. Where
was he going? Dong skip stare in America.
What's that in America. You can you do
this? Yeah. San Francisco. You sure?
Yeah. Girls. He was walking in a
room with dogs. They were naked.
The girls are naked.
And I are the only ones with clothes
on because we worked with each other.
Send in immigration,
send IC
alert. Yeah. There's something going on
that Bro. It's just dicks everywhere.
Open that door. You, you cool with decks
in front of you? I'm not. I was here.
I was looking away. Cops just come in
and fucking masks on Madonna alert. Yeah,
they throw one of those. What are those?
Uh, gas canisters that flash bangs.
Just grabbing guys by their dogs.
Pulling them out until the paddy wagon.
It would all run out. Grab there. Dot.
That's the first thing you've got to grab.
Someone throws a tear gas
canister to explodes in a room.
I'm wearing pants so I was
the only one with pants on.
And you can kind of feel like everyone
was looking at you like you're making us
feel like shamed because you're wearing
pants when it's just taking them off.
But I couldn't, I'm with my po.
That's a tactic. That's what that is.
That's a tactic. Yeah. What
kind of, what do you mean?
It's a tactic they're trying to
like, come on man. Shows your Dick.
This is how you show up when you did.
You get together with five of your buddies
and you all are real comfortable with
seeing each other's dicks.
We're going to get to see Mikey's Dick.
How are you gonna do that?
We're going to shame them.
I'm going to shame them in and showing
us his dick and we're going to take our
dicks out.
We're going to walk into that steam room.
I just going to let your nuts hang.
Why does everyone want to see what
the fuck are you doing with your,
but take your God damn pants off and
he'll be like go road or road. Jesus.
Why does everyone want to
see Mikey so bad? Cause Mike,
he probably has a little Dick, which
dance on? That's, that's what I felt like.
I felt like everybody thinks I have a
small one because I got my pants up,
but that's not it. Um,
purely for research purposes.
I was a online the other night
googling into Dick Surgery,
Dick and large and surgery. It was after
that billionaire guy actually died. What?
Yeah, he was a diamond dealer. He was
in his sixties and I want to say he was,
I dunno, it was in Europe
or somewhere. Anyway,
homeboy got some Dick Surgery.
Lans died on the operating table.
Wow. I didn't even know they're
doing that. She surgery. You don't,
you don't let me,
my grandmother had a saying don't let
anyone mess with your eyes or your Dick.
Yeah, there it is. He Goes, uh, the
gentlemen had been hug. Where you going?
Um,
he a heart attack in the middle
of the procedure, which isn't Fda
approved and then says, is it safe?
Dunton I think anytime you go
under it's not 100% safe and hey,
anytime putting you under
and cutting you open.
I went under for the first time
last month. It was an anesthetic,
death souls from the anesthetic. That's
what I'm saying. They put you wonder men,
you could fucking die. I know. I was
worried about it and he's an older fellow.
I think that guy was in his sixties
includes surgical lengthening,
which involves cutting a ligament.
Hey,
at the base of the penis or filler
injections. I'll go with filler.
Let's see what you do with filler first
and then if I'm going to cut my deck
later, stage two, they're
gonna use a filler. Cocky,
foamy spray into the insulation
and they come through the asshole.
What does this implant
for men? Ah, Jeez. Ooh.
All clicked. I don't know.
Fall into, hold on. Hold on.
You're going to shove plastic and your
Dick. Is that what that guy has? Yeah,
like a sling. Hold on. I'll go low. Stop,
stop, stop, stop, stop, stop scrolling.
Get off this page animation, but
no, no. Look at this thing you have.
You can pick your size. It's
a sleeve. It's like a sleeve.
You didn't show that Dick on TV or on us.
Just for you guys.
Well then pull it up, bro. Work they,
they can stick the extra long. What
if you're like, oh my God. Oh my God,
this is so bad, but we're
looks like an gutter. A Shin.
It looks like a little piece of gutter.
A small incision is made just above the
base of the penis where your pubes are
and the, okay. Then they slide
it down into your shaft. I got,
I got one word for everybody.
What is it? Infection. Ah,
what have you got? A Dick Infection. Oh
my God. I have one word for you. Popular
to think that works. Implanted,
secure. Now hidden sutures,
which are generally not detectable
by a patient or whatever.
So you have like this
sleeve inside the skin.
I'll tell you what's going on now though,
in porn. This is some real shit they,
they have,
they have GMOs only takes an hour.
There's Gmo Dick's now you're way bigger.
I was watching that old porn film
with a John Hayes when we were kids.
John Holmes was the guy
with the biggest debt.
John Holmes has irregular Dick compared
to porn stars for real especially,
and this sounds racist.
Black eyes.
Well of course this is in
the right direction though.
I supplied to the day that it was like,
that can't be real.
That literally can't be real. His
Dick was so big. It was preposterous.
He probably had an 18 inch
dick 1818 inch deck. It was so,
and it was thick around as your
fucking risk. It was ridiculous.
There was a girl who was trying
to suck on it. I was like, see,
I don't think the girls want that.
Girls like this. I mean, I don't know,
maybe the girl was 50 pounds. I
don't think she, even if she was,
he still had a 12 inch dick gigantic.
It was so ridiculously big
that as was watching this film,
I was like,
okay,
what's happened over the last 2030
years with porn that we've evolved?
Yeah.
He just got a lot of guys that have a,
in the recruitment that,
yeah, I guess, right.
The perception of what a Dick was from
like, yeah, here's what I'm saying.
Like there's this implant that may or
may not work that we just watched that
little commercial for and it's brutal.
Yeah. But outside of that, yeah.
What would, cause like a girl of girls
wanted bigger boobs. They get a boob job.
That's common. Yeah. We're used to
that. But guys with giant Dicks,
I don't think they're getting operations.
I think just these are just a
crop of dudes with giant takes.
You know,
a new class of guys showed up.
They're on another level
through Leah dicks are so big.
This recruiting and the fuck.
We've had a real great draft this year.
It's different.
It's like people,
the big Dick dudes from like the 1970s
and eighties they had kids with people
ate a lot of vitamins.
Maybe it was an optical illusion
because we had more pubes back then.
It was coming out of the forest. You
didn't see half of no, no, no, no, no,
no. This guy was, these guys are massive.
Kind of had a snake. Yeah. It was a snake.
It was a fat snake that you would
like capture in the everglades.
This is why I kept my pants on at the
Banya. I didn't want people intimidate.
If you've got a dick like that, you
just swing that thing anywhere you want.
Whenever you want. It cares. Who Cares?
Well, anyway, I shared this black white
dudes that have giant dicks too. I just,
there's a couple.
I'm not seeing them.
I'm not seeing him at the same with
the same. I'm just being honest.
The limited amount of research that
I've done is there is a difference
for I think what your defense mechanism
was, right? Like rightly to say.
Yeah, women don't want that.
They don't want their giant Dick.
That hurts him every time I get it, bro.
Come on. I know where you're coming from.
You know I want my ladies to be happy,
not upset.
Some girls want to be upset.
That guy,
by the way,
billionaire in his sixties and
even thinking about it stored,
why are you even these board?
Isn't that amazing?
Like if you've got that much
money's top and think about that,
you're in your sixties
you got that much money,
you have billions of dollars and how much
time do you have left and what do you
do with your money and what
do you do with your time?
You know the good dudes probably
fucking board of Shit we owe.
Has it come down to sex? Why not just
get a hobby? You're so old. Timing.
Each injection of hyaluronic acid fillers
cost between 250 and $750 and adds
girth.
Ro said person.
Patients usually begin with about 10,
10 injections,
injection filler injection. Woo. Wow.
Jesus Christ.
That's not good.
The patient could have given
him general anesthesia,
which may be exacerbated heart conditions.
Oh, Jesus Christ. Scad heart. He had
a heart condition. This guy. Yeah.
See they live at, you know what?
Hold on. Put that back on. It says,
if you're getting general anesthesia and
you have an underlying malady in your
heart, you will unmask that
and it will show itself.
Jesus. People are so bored. So all this
money and it just makes you more board.
Yeah. Ridiculous. I think
people just get on a path.
Right? And what is the path? The
Path is to, to acquire success. Yeah.
And when you're doing something
like selling diamonds, you know,
congratulations for making a lot of money.
People like to buy diamonds,
but what are you doing? What
are you doing? Those diamonds?
And you're buying diamonds, you're
selling diamonds, you're buying diamond,
and you're getting older and you're,
you're, you're like, oh my God,
I'm at the end of the ride. When am I
doing? What was this right about? Um,
I'm not dexilant figured out, fuck
Aa and one. Then we're going in,
we're going to take anesthesia,
we're going to get a dick fixed.
But because he was just
essentially moving money around,
he wasn't making something easy.
You think that's it?
That there was no worth
to what he was doing?
I think just like he wasn't being
satisfied mentally with his job,
with his work.
With his life.
Yeah. I think there's probably a lot
of people in his sort of position.
A lot of people who are billionaires who
are financier's and bankers and stuff
where they're probably in a similar
spot where they're like, what do what?
Unless they have something they really
enjoy doing outside of work, you know,
it really captivates their time and that's
their passion. That's the case. Brow.
You're 65 get out. Yeah.
Get out of the work. Yes.
Stops that. Just get a different hot.
Wow. What are you doing? Yeah, but,
but the other thing is when you're
around people like that, right?
And this is not a bad thing.
It's a life choice.
But if you're around philosophy people,
if you're a person who likes Rolls Royces
and giant mansions and you know you
liked a baller,
I've got a big fat diamond ring
lifestyle that guys around those people,
because he's selling diamond
rings, selling diamonds, diamonds.
Mother fucker got billions for
$48 million. Ooh, look at
that blue, a blue diamond,
48 48 million has a father
bought it for his daughter.
Wow. Magic rock. Damn. Imagine if you're
the daughter and you lose that Shit,
you're out drinking.
You know you,
you're fucking pull your panties down
the P and a curb cause you're so god.
I'm so fucking Hammond.
And I rang,
my dad's going to kill slips right
off while you're throwing up,
throwing up in a dumpster,
uh, my dad's going to kill me. Yeah,
maybe the daughter was 40.
It makes you realize that the things that
you read that really give you worth in
life is not the Joe.
It's something that's going to engage
your head and make you feel a little
useful.
You're way better off having less dough
and something you really love. Yeah,
but that's only if you have a certain
amount of dough. That's the problem. Yeah.
The stress of not having
enough money to feed yourself,
feed your family and a roof over your
head. That's overwhelming for people.
Especially as we were
talking about earlier.
If people have fucking credit card
debt or student loan debt or some
insurmountable amount of debt that
can't get out of it just hangs on you,
then you're not really thinking
about what's meaningful for my what,
so it's meaningful hobby for me.
Oh Dude, it's the worst. Yeah.
The feeling of debt is the fucking worst.
And then the feeling of just working
for nothing. That's also bad too.
There's the feeling of like every day
you're doing it just to exist and at the
end of the day you're exhausted. So
what is your life? What is your life?
Is your w your life, all this
shit you hate to do yet? Well,
that's the answer for most people.
Most people,
most of the time the answer is you're
doing something you hate to do.
And it's been me, and I know it's
been you at some point in your life,
but God damn the,
the amount that your life can change if
you just no longer have to do something
you don't want to do, you could do
something that you actually enjoy.
Whatever it is,
whether it's carpentry or painting or
whatever the fuck it is that you love to
do. Do you think it has to be your work
or do you think you could be at work or
you're like kind of into it, but then
you have some other passion that's good,
that satisfied. But you're also,
if, if your work isn't satisfying,
that's most of your life. Yeah. You gotta
do what you gotta do. Of course you do.
Of course you have to do what you gotta
do. That goes without saying. Yeah.
So figuring out a way out of there,
everybody's got a way out. Don't just,
people love to say things like that. Like,
Hey, some people don't have that luxury.
People love to say things like that. So
you have to acknowledge that, but that's,
that's the case with anyone who has ever
done anything where it was hard to do.
Right. It's always, it's always
going to be hard to do that,
that it's used for you to say it.
Of course. It's easy for me to say.
I'm just saying that's the
easiest thing in the world.
I'm going to put a rocket on the moon.
See, I just said, wow. Say exactly.
I'm going. Of course, it's easy to say,
but the difference just as
a person who's done bolt,
the difference between doing something
you hate doing and doing something you
love doing, it's off the charts. How
much better your life is. No, absolutely.
You're making less money even if you're
making less money. Exactly. Because like,
you know, to use comedy as an
example, because it's what we are.
When you were making $5 a night,
literally $5 a night as a comedian,
I was so much happier than when I had
a day job. Oh yeah. Making real money.
Once the,
I remember the feeling of being able
to make a living with just stand up.
Yeah. Like what? Like holy can and
not a good living. Just getting by.
And my beginning, it was
super shaky. Shaky, right?
Like I started making money. I was making
like a little bit of money in Boston,
but always had day jobs when I
moved to New York. And then, uh,
Jeff started managing me.
Then I started making money.
Like he'd get me booked
in places and I was doing,
I was working pretty much every weekend.
Who Was Jeff? Jeff Sussman. Sussman,
longtime manager. Started managing me
when I was at open Miker Oh, nice. Yeah.
We've been together forever. Well, he's
the best. He's still with them. Yup. Wow.
That's amazing. Best. That's amazing. He's
the best. I love the guy. That's great.
He's an awesome person too and
just a brilliant at his job.
Super Low key. Doesn't give a fuck about
Hollywood. Oh, that's great. But you know,
he's, he's, he understands it. He knows
what to do. Right. He hasn't care.
It was like to do what makes you happy
once he just wants you to be happy.
It's awesome. So he picked you up when
you're doing open mikes too. Dude,
I'll scrub it wasn't even supposed to
go on stage that night. Really? Yeah.
He came into town. He had managed some
other comedians. You Remember Bob Nelson?
No, Bob Nelson Jeffy Jeff football
guy. Oh my God. He didn't manage him.
Really? Yeah, he produced
his HBO special and um,
they were parting ways and uh,
they were parting ways and Jeff was like,
well maybe I've seen everybody
that I've seen in a New York,
maybe I'll take a trip to Boston.
So he took a trip to Boston
and just fucking dumb luck
when I was driving limos,
I wrote a joke that day. I had this
joke and I called up my friend Oliver,
who was the manager at the
club and I said, hey man,
can I come in and do like five minutes
cause I have this joke I want to try out.
I said, sure, come on in. And he liked me.
So he hooked me up and I went on stage
and I didn't even know Sussman who was in
the room when, cause I didn't know he
was in the room. I didn't give a fuck.
I was super loose. You knew who he
was at that point? No, I didn't know.
I knew that there was a manager from
New York that handled Bob Nelson.
I'd be like, Holy Shit. I'd
probably freak out. Sure I'd choke.
I mean, back to shaky is fuck back
then anyway, you know, I'm only like,
of course we wouldn't have three years
in a colony, so eat that. I was terrible.
Yeah. Anything did often.
It was really interesting.
Like he took me to New York to
um, he saw me there and then, uh,
he took me to New York to try out.
He wanted to see me perform in
some other clubs. So he said, we,
are you willing to come down in
New York? So I said, sure. Yeah,
I've always wanted to. I was so nervous
about performing in New York, of course.
Thought New York City was different.
It was like more nervous.
Then when he came to see me
the second time in Boston,
I was more nervous to perform in New York.
It's like,
I can't believe I was one of it. Catch a
rising star, which doesn't exist anymore.
Just legends. Forget it. Your
head. Yeah. That's a big thing.
It's an because you don't know it yet.
Yeah.
Well it was like the New York comics
were always like the smart ones.
Yeah. That was the thought process.
The insecure thought process in Boston.
Like the audiences are smarter than not
going to buy your bullshit smarter over
there. Yeah, I know you're not fun and
you're going to know they're gonna know.
And uh,
it's really funny.
It's like sossman we were talking about
like clean comedy versus dirty comedy
and there was no really real
decision like, you know,
because back then people
would like decide to be clean.
It wasn't like you're a clean comic
because that's how you think. Well,
if you want get more work,
the smart
moves through the clean as a business
decision, as a business decision.
It should dress nice and act clean.
Took me to this place called, uh, we,
we went to a bunch of places.
It did eat side comedy club,
which is a cool comedy club
that used to be in long island.
Then he took me this place called fast
eddies and Huntington. And it was a,
it was a local bar that
had a comedy night. Wow.
And we went upstairs and it was so,
the crowd was so fucking rowdy and so
drunk and there was a dude on stage.
His name was George Gallows,
hilarious dude who, uh,
was doing a reverse shit with a banana.
He was like, as you're waiting to go
on. So he had a banana that he was like,
he was somehow or another slurping it.
Like it was a reverse shit.
And he's doing this in front of,
you know, these people are hammered.
It's like a Wednesday night or some
shit. Right. And Psas and says,
he grabs me by the arm. You don't
have to perform here. We're going to,
we're going to get out of it. And I
said, no fucking way. I go, listen man.
To my people. I go, I go, just trust me.
Let me go out my paper. I'm
like, this is what I do, man.
All the gigs that I got in Boston
for all bargains handle this. Yeah.
You got hard. You get
tough. Yeah. We'll also,
plus it's once you've done a bunch
of them, it's like chaos. It's fun.
You know what to do, what
to do. Yeah, for sure.
It's a different kinds of
comments like combat comedy,
which was at that time you ran into
that more than you didn't run into that.
Even today,
if you get a road gigs,
if you're a up and coming
guy or gal and you get wrote,
especially if you're a Gao, girls got
get it way harder in the early days,
like people like my friends girlfriend
admitted the other day that when she sees
a female comedian at a comedy club,
she cringes still to this day.
She goes,
I get super uncomfortable when they
start going on stage and when they're,
if they're funny, it's a huge
relief. I'm like, isn't that crazy?
As a feminist, I hate saying that. It's
terrible is I consider myself a feminist.
I hate saying, I feel like it's gotten
beyond that. I feel like there's so many,
oh yeah.
Such strong at the top of the chain,
but if you're in some weird club in the
middle of nowhere and some, yeah, I get,
I get the, I get that fee. I get like,
especially if you're a
feminist and you were around,
you just don't want her to
bomb cause then you think,
well they're all the rest of the audience
is going to think that's what all
women are. Right. That too.
And there's that. She just
doesn't think they're funny.
Very often she uses, she's not a comic,
so she's just being honest about it.
And we were laughing because when a
girl says that you're like, oh no.
But back then it was like eight
every time. Even in like good clubs,
like the comic strip or Caroline's,
it was just like, it was war war.
It was war,
but nothing compared to like the the get,
did you ever get any of those Bob Gonzo
Gigs in New Jersey? Oh yeah. Oh God.
Yeah. It was like a frat party.
That memory just threw you up.
They didn't want comedy. Then
those comedy, oh they turn you,
they sees in you in a different way.
They season you for like,
like the comedy store was similar to that
for a long time cause the comedy store
in the early days had no crowd control.
Literally zero. Right. So the crowd
was in. It is in control sometimes.
No one ever shot anybody
up. No. But the new regime,
it's handled so much differently was
a new concept. It's so much better,
so much better. But it did
make you bulletproof. Yeah.
You knew how to handle drunk.
You came through that era,
through that time or maybe it still
exists when you're going through,
but if you do that many gigs,
that's why I don't,
I really don't believe in just going to
your one little alt room over and over
again where you know you're coddled and
supported and I really believe that you
have to go into all these
hellish situations. So you just,
anywhere you go,
you know you can go and kill.
That's an important part to
being a comedian. And you also,
as you become a successful comedian,
you could fall into the trap
of only performing in front
of your audience. Right.
You know, you really do have to drop
in on other people's shows right here.
People don't know who you are and why.
Yeah.
That's what's great about
the storyline up to right.
There's 15 comedians and they're
probably not there to see you now.
Where to see this guy or that car
or, yeah, no, it's great. You know,
you have to be able to survive because
you see people that come out of those
other environments and then they
get thrown into this and they,
they don't know how to act.
I think comedy is like a lot of
other things that are difficult.
There's things that you can do
to get better at those. You know,
like they say that like if you take,
if you learn languages,
you could get better at chess.
I read something about that. Does
that make sense? Did I make that up?
That sounds about right.
I would learn a new language.
It'll make you better at chess.
I might've made that up.
It's just the way your mind is.
Trying to think if all the different
like cross training methods,
how can it be better at chess? Do you play
chess? No, but I want to but I'm scared.
It's fun. I'm scared. Why you
saw me play quake earlier?
I have addiction, crazy addiction
problems. Chesses is addicting.
Tom Papa walked in and Jeff and I were
going to war all we keep going at it.
It was the most intense thing I've ever
seen you do isn't as dense accidents.
Both of you on the keyboard and the
thing sweating your ass off in front of
these monitors. You were taking like
deep, deep breaths in the middle of it.
Do you sketch is just firing off
at each other. It was intense.
You ought to try to stay calm and these
were in this very small map so I always
know where he is.
He always knows where I am and there's
a limited amount of ammunition and armor
and when you get jacked and you come
back less strong with a weaker weapon,
you've got to run to get a good weapon
quick and then you've got to run to get
where the fucking armor is and he knows
where that shit is. So it's a crazy dual,
like oftentimes if he kills me,
he'll kill me two or three times in a row.
It was so much faster than I
thought it was going to be. Oh yeah.
I mean in real intense, is it always
that like you're just in one four yard,
one stone court yard running around
many, many maps. You can just go, yeah,
that's a good one for
one on one. Oh, okay.
We have these one on one matches the
most fun because there's no other
variables. Right. The variables of like
if there's like 10 people, the Roman,
everybody's shooting everybody,
which is a lot of these maps.
I'll show you that too.
That's bring more chaos.
Oftentimes you get killed when you are
fighting a guy and then someone comes
from behind. You. Didn't even see
him and they shoot you some knowing.
So how addicting is this for you?
Oh, real. Real. It's a real problem.
You used to do it right?
Yeah, I'm way better at now.
I'll do it like for an hour and then
I'll stop and then you'll be good.
In the old days it's very different,
but everything's addictive to me, man.
Every time now. All of it.
Anything I like, I like,
it's like it becomes addictive.
That's why your shoulder's messed up.
That's from Jujitsu, but it's not, the
shoulder was more of a maintenance thing.
It wasn't,
it wasn't that bad.
It was just getting a little sore and I
wanted to get looked at and there's some
tendinitis in there. Right. So I just,
I'm real proactive at 51 I have to
be real proactive about injuries.
When things feel squirrely,
he, and it's the problem.
You can get hurt and then you can't work
out anymore. Yeah, I like it too much.
I like 'em, but even if it's not
something as intense as Jujitsu,
I just need to do something.
Whether it's yoga or running is like me.
No workout me workout.
I like me when I work out so much more.
I like me better. It happened to
me in San Francisco after the day.
After the bond. Yeah. I'm just, I
just woke up. I had good shows Friday.
I'm just like, but I just woke
up like kissed in a shitty mood,
just kind of Eh,
eh.
And I knew if I could just get
my shoes on and go for a run,
I hold days going to be different.
Yup.
And it's just a half hour just
going out doing and come back.
And I was a totally in the same room,
just feeling completely different.
Not Crazy.
It's just a mental shit.
You're flooding your brain with all the
beautiful thoughts and ideas that happen
in there. And while you're
running, while you're breathing,
he got all these fucking ideas that
come to your brand and get interested.
You're breathing and you're running
your concert. And he brought me,
I'll slow down a little bit here. So what
does it look better? Then you're like,
fuck yeah, we're out here doing
it. I am running. Woo. Yeah.
It's a big deal. Who knows what chemicals
are firing off in your brain? Man, dude,
it's my dog and me because we run
together. Oh, like inseparable.
Really. Just crazy. It's
hilarious. He follows me
everywhere. Like when I sit down,
he sits right next to me.
I've never had a relationship
with a dog like this.
Dogs that I loved that were great, but
this dog is like stuck to me like glue.
It's, it's so great. Part of
it is because we run so much,
so thrilled.
He
used to,
so when we run he turns and he'll run
ahead of me and then we'll come back to me
to check up on me when it comes back
and runs with like this big smile on his
face. Like I can't believe
it's Ron runs again.
How far are you running with him?
A couple of miles.
That's grills is a pretty steep hills.
Oh, that's good. That's a workout. If I'm,
if I have a short time,
you can do a little, uh,
there's one real steep trail that I run.
There's once each other we have
to drive to a little bit tasty,
but it's super steep. Oh yeah. It's a way
out near like a Gora. That one's rough.
That's a rough one. That's gotta be
tough. Yeah, because it's real long.
It's like the whole thing is the hills
because the hills are no pounding. Right.
You can get a good hill under
you. It's way harder. So I just,
I base it on 140 beats a minute.
Anytime I get below 140 beats a minute,
I just start running again. But I'll do
these sprints. I'll go as far as I can.
I get it into one eighties and then when
I'm like, fuck, I gotta take a break,
I'll just take a break and I'll look
at my heartbeat, get my heartbeat down,
note somewhere in the one
40 is 40 anywhere around
one 45 then I'm ready to go
again and then I'll go again.
And I'm usually like one
sixties you know, running,
it's, it's rough hills or
rough, really rough and thing,
but it's changed my kicking power. Oh,
he actually gave me more kicking power.
Yeah, I can kick, believe it
or not, it's probably like,
I want to say like 10%, five or
10% more power from the runs. Yeah.
My pips or bigger muscles around my,
uh,
like my butt.
Like the hip area right where your belt
is like right below where your belt.
I never had a muscle there. Right.
What is that crazy from the hills?
This is all from running hills.
So when I stopped,
like if I stomped the about
like a front kick to the bag,
that that four thrust is the same
thing you're doing all the time.
When you're running,
you're running,
you're pushing off one leg and you
pushing off the other leg and you push
because you're going up a hill.
So when you're kicking,
you're pushing off that leg and trusting
that other leg forward. It's crazy.
Is your dog a good on the hills? Does,
does your dog ever get tired? Yeah,
he gets tired. He gets, we know
when they get tired, they get tired.
When you throw the ball then
it's a sprint. It's a sprint.
And then you bring it back, bring it
back here and it's like seven times like,
y'all bro, I'm coming to lie
down over here. You're like,
no, no, no. Come on man.
Give me that ball.
Come on man.
My sister has to put down her dog tonight.
16 year old dog,
a big like, um, like almost like a
spaniel kind of thing. Wow. 16 years.
And she's just,
she's just been hanging on and she's just
been the greatest and tonight seven 30
just has to go and just, there's no
joy left. She just can't go anymore.
It's going to be rough. I've talked
to her on my way and it's just like,
what a brutal thing to have to do.
16 years,
my dog got hit by a car
when I was like 14. Oh
14 or 15,
right in front of me taking her
across the street and we had,
we had a busy street and her house and
some car came down the street really fast.
Ah, she got off the leash and ran right
into this, hit her in a Volkswagen.
Ah, yeah. It was rough to
it. I brought her up, stuck,
carried her up to the house.
Did she die instantly?
She died and like
she died and looked in like 1520
minutes. That's so brutal. It's rough.
She started shitting all over the place.
How old was she? She wasn't that old.
Maybe five or six. It's brutal.
There's nothing worse. Yeah.
So painful. Sweet dog too.
Yeah, it was a bomber man.
She just loved being in the park and we
were heading to the park and she just
got a little too excited and ran, you
know, I didn't see the car coming.
Ah, I didn't get ahold of her collar.
And Tom, it's brutal. It was so bad.
It was so bad. She, but she, you
know, she got knocked flying.
I didn't even know she was going to die.
You couldn't tell.
It was all the injuries were internal.
Brought her upstairs.
She started shitting herself,
started shitting all over the place.
It was very unusual for her. She
was, she's house trained, you know,
and I was really scared.
Have you had to go through any pet
deaths with your kids yet? Yeah, the two,
my two dogs.
So I just had to put both of my dogs down.
My dogs are around rational.
Yeah. Yeah. They were, um,
13 it was a massive, and he
was 13. Wow. That's great.
Run at the end. I used to have
to carry him into the house.
Yeah. He couldn't walk anymore. He
would walk like literally, we'd be like,
he would walk it's step, walk us down,
you stay in his legs would be shaking.
Had the kids handle it and they
were really sad. It's hard, man.
Isn't that the hardest thing when you
watch your kids have to deal with it?
So it makes it so much
harder. Yeah. I mean it's,
but trying to be brave. I think there's
a lesson in it, you know, for real.
I think it's a,
it's not a good experience,
but I think it's good for them to
experience. Oh yeah, yeah, absolutely.
That's what they have to go through
it, you know, like pet death and,
and just this,
having those little relationships
with animals. When you're a kid,
it's like your dog.
You could always talk to them and oh yeah,
you can say crazy shit to your dog and
now you're talking to be sitting in your
room with you and you go, you
know what? It's just you and me.
You're the only one understands me. Woo.
You're parents are acting like assholes.
No one likes you in the house,
but your Doug still does ship
yells at me and going over on your way.
You're going to come with me.
Let's go out.
I'm taking the dog mom.
Oh,
it's the past.
But watching your kids like trying
to be brave and trying not to cry.
That is such a heartbreaker.
Just trying to be like, oh,
I'm okay. Oh, it's just the worst.
He was like, kill me. Hey deedee,
notice deep up by your house,
we have mosquitoes now.
Really? We have like legit.
Then we never had mosquitoes out here.
There's just like real mosquitoes and
they bite you only from like your knee
down. Everybody round where I
live is saying the same thing.
We've never had mosquitoes. If you just
wear pants, then your problem is solved.
I only wear pants. So how they bite in
you? Well, I take my shoes off on some of,
I don't do that. You're right
though. I have noticed mosquitoes.
I noticed some last night. We never
had them in southern California before.
I don't know where they're coming
from. Well, we definitely had them.
We just didn't have many of them.
And this is how I know we had them.
I moved into a house once in Encino and
no one had lived there for like at least
a year, I think. And the
pool had not been tended to.
So the pool was filled
with mosquito larva. Ooh.
It's like fish, like schools of
fish. Oh my God. Around there.
And I was freaking out. I was like, what
is that? These fish. And I hired this guy,
Kevin, the pool guy. Kevin, the pool
guy came over and he was like, Brooklyn,
those are mosquito
larva. Oh my God. No. Oh,
maybe that's where they all came
from. It's a new thing. I mean,
we used to have our doors open or
windows up and no screens, no problem.
But now all of a sudden, just this
last year. Yeah, we're so sad.
You have to live like the rest of
the world now. Why do I live here
if I have to put screens on my windows?
Do you think that'll last? Will it change?
I don't know.
Have you heard about this?
Did you see that shit that I posted
yesterday about that yellow mustard plant?
Yeah, black monster looks beautiful.
I was like, oh, that's nice.
And it was the most though. I'm at this
posting though. What's very strange man,
because this shit didn't exist before.
Like I never saw like on the same hills
where I'm seeing it dominate the hill.
It literally didn't exist a year ago and
now it's just like an invasive plant.
It's crazy plant.
I just looked up my skills in Los Angeles
and the thing starts an article from
the end of last year,
but it says,
have you experienced an unusual number
of mosquitoes bites the summer? Mostly,
but no, excuse me. Mostly below the
knee and especially around your ankles.
How about that?
It's a called an aid.
It's called eighties and
the aids an aids bug.
You have eighties 80 e d e s and
that's a real problem, right? Yeah,
it's a problem. It's a real problem.
It says, what do I live in Spain?
He just read it. E D e s and it's
a real problem. That's funny.
Here's spreading like wildfire.
So Susan [inaudible],
director of scientific and technical
research services for the greater Los
Angeles County Vector Control district.
Sounds like Suzanne needs
money for fucking business.
That's what sounds like to me. Or
our phones are exploding. Fake News.
Kidding. Los Angeles is home
to two particularly troubling
types of invasive ADSL
mosquitoes. Oh man, they're going fast.
The Asian Tiger mosquito arrived first
having hitched a ride with shipments of
lucky bamboo from China.
You and your bamboo.
I don't think my pole barbells
thing. It's like a polymer. China.
In 2001 vector control
specialists monitored plant
nurseries across the county
and soon stopped finding the
mosquitoes in their traps.
They thought the insects
had been eradicated.
Whoever in 2011 residents in El Monte
began complaining about unusually
aggressive daytime biting mosquitoes
plaguing the neighborhood. Yes.
In the daytime.
Ms This is happening.
They even a infiltrated.
What do you think would happen if people
started seeing malaria in America?
That can, why hasn't that
happened? Good question.
I'm sure doctor Peter Hotez could have
explained that to us right when he was
talking about infectious diseases from
malaria is a hilarious,
I know when I was still living in Ohio,
West Nile virus to pop up a lot
with mosquitoes. Do not like,
not like every day or anything like that,
but I know that had to spray certain
neighborhoods all the time like stay and
keep your kids and keep your pet.
Samara spraying your neighbor morale.
I didn't sign up for this.
How about,
how about signing up for spraying in the
West Nile because the spray is going to
get to everybody. They used to spray
when I was a kid in New Jersey,
they would spray for the Gypsy
moths, Jesus, they just come with,
they wouldn't even tell us that.
It's just like look at that plane and
shit would be coming out of its ass end.
Think of the difference between the way
a butterfly gets treated and a moth.
Yeah.
Robots deserve it.
Dirty. Isn't it funny? It's a little,
they're a little chalky and
they have a plain color.
We've got like that base around
their head and then the same thing,
the other gray or white,
but it's only the way they look.
He had the butterflies
putable but isn't that crazy?
Orange and black like we love them. Love
them. You find a spider, you stomp it.
You would never go to a zoo and go into
the moth house. If you kill a lady bug,
you're an asshole. Oh, completely. You're
a type of person who kills lady bugs.
Yeah, but if you don't kill
Roach, I can't hang out with you.
If you let a roach run across the
kitchen floor and he likes hot nom roach,
sadness, I save all.
Kill that fucking thing.
You got to Roche in your kitchen lady.
But
a lady has a couple dots on it. Why are
we racist with bugs? Because there's,
this has such a thing as beauty.
Okay.
That's why squirrels get a pass and
rats don't. Yes. Bushy tail. Yeah.
Look in kill style like a fringe jacket
matches a tail was just because they
found that if the tails group bushy
people would stop killing them. Yeah.
I mean what's more disgusting than just
a skin tail with nothing on it. Oh,
awesome. Oh awesome. Tail possums.
Don't even cause any problems.
See possum Taylor. Oh, you
little fucking Getcha Bat.
Little hands. Little hands
and your little tail. Oh,
beady eyes. Yeah. Disgusting. Yeah,
but like we have certain animals
that we like, like raccoons. Look,
we don't wreck like raccoons and they're
eating out of your garbage button. Now,
if someone had a pet raccoon, you would
think that's the dopest thing ever.
Can we have, we secretly
want relationships. Raccoons.
If they would only be nicer to us,
right? We would embrace raccoons.
Raccoons don't want to have shit to do
with us. They don't. I don't get it.
They're smart. Too smart
for us. We're nice to them.
I thought these people are
assholes. Sweets, they go to
sleep and eat their trash.
We'll just eat their garbage. Savory,
eat their garbage. They put lids on it.
That shit doesn't work. They've got
that cool black mass lift the lid.
You throw it aside to pull the bag out.
They'll hands.
I know if people hands they do
with a little tiny people. Hey,
I know you can grab stuff. Smoke
cigarettes hanging out. Yeah, the text.
They also wanna kill
chickens. Well, so do we.
Do you know who's a real predator?
Skunks. Skunks are predators.
There's a skunk living in the
back of my yard. Sprayed my dog.
Oh No, it's still there.
I think so. Come on, Bro.
Man Out. What am I going to do?
Take out the skunk hazmat suit.
He'd begun time to go to war.
I got to go crawl into the thing and
find them crawling to the thing. He goes,
look, it is fucking shit's crazy.
It's like he's flaunting.
He's like, yeah, look at that.
His hand is so much smaller than his face.
It's crazy.
Imagine if your hand was that small and
relationship to is the size of your head.
He's adorable though, isn't he? He is cute
little fella. He's like, look at, look,
you think I've stayed out of your garbage?
No Way. Look what I'm working with.
Did they have opposable thumbs?
I'm working with,
didn't quite seem like
five fingers with no thumb.
Right. That's the thing. They never
figured out. Look at his teeth.
They never figured it out.
Like they had meetings as hands dudes.
We just need a thumb. Let
me see the teeth. There we
go. He's got his mouth open.
That whoa, that would, that would
really hurt. Fucking suck. Look,
one of them is chipped. If, uh,
yeah, from biting you in the head.
Do you think if a racker tattoo
you could fight it off? No.
Well you could stomp it.
What'd you do? What'd you give
up? It might cut your neck.
When would you decide we're going to to
the death immediately. Immediately? Yeah.
He wouldn't try to talk to raccoon out
of this. No. Soon as he makes a move.
I'm ready because I've been
thinking about it since childhood.
Oh look at that one. I don't want that one
bite my nose. Yeah, it was like a Hyena.
The raccoon I made that thing.
I've been thinking these things
are coming after us my whole life.
So if he makes a move, it's on, Bro.
Those teeth are God damn terrifying. Yes.
Look at those teeth now. And
they're sneaky. That's a big thing.
And they're filled with rabies
filled. Yeah, to the top.
Like their balls are heavy with rates.
It's just oozing out of him
to water balloons. Raccoons,
Swisher burning his is touch. Ooh,
I touch raccoons.
Rely on their hands more than
their eyes and going touch.
You study suggested the sensitivity to
touch increases when their hands are wet,
which might be why they
always wash their food. Why?
I just washed my hands and now I am
going to touch you when you sleep.
I ain't going to touch you and your
children while you were sleeping with my
finger hands that give a rat was as
big as a raccoon and try to kill you.
You'd be fucking terrified. No,
we'd be, we'd be spraying. Oh,
if there were rats. Size things.
Just go on through La. Yeah.
But why do you think we'll
spray for these mosquitoes?
I think it's time to call our congressman.
Well,
I think that everyone's
afraid of chem trails.
And if you start sprang gs
circling greater Los Angeles
drop and poisoned down.
That's the wrapped with the pizza.
I've seen that. Oh yeah, the pizza rat.
That's he's famous. Rats are
disgusting too. They're pretty gross.
You ever seen that Netflix
documentary on rats? No. Oh.
Oh No. Really? Oh Dude. Really? Yeah.
You need to watch it because it's um,
it's educational.
It's not just gross and it's really gross.
But when you realize how many of them
there really are in major cities. Yeah,
the bio mass of them. It's
a fuck stunning. Really.
All rat.
It's just rats.
As many rat is more or somewhere in the
neighborhood of as many rats as there
are people really.
And there's 8 million people and there's
how many more as or more she's just,
Oh, I mean you see them non stop
walking around and just guessing.
Obviously most of them are subterranean.
Most of them are living in
houses and most of them,
I mean they burrow their way into tiny
little holes. How long does the rat live?
It's good question. How long does
the rat live? Because they're born,
there's a lot of them,
but do they stick around for like 20
years to the documentary showed how they
send young rats to try
out poison. Really? Yeah.
The old suicide rats, they send them out
there cause they don't know any better.
They let them die. They're just assholes.
Wow. Yeah. They, here's a little tip,
if they're ever doing construction
in New York in front of a restaurant,
you don't need it. You don't
need on that street. Why?
Because they're digging it up.
Whatever their little ecosystem
is and they're just so,
if they're digging up the street,
they're dying somewhere else.
I would imagine in New York, it must be
so hard to keep them out of a restaurant.
Oh, it's gotta be so hard. I guess maybe
leave some in the dumpster for him.
Like he'd give a lego
monsters. Just the head. Yeah.
Like when they was to tie the
girl into the stakes for Kong.
So you'd leave everybody else alone
and a little shish Kebab stick.
It's like your last job when you're
closing down the restaurant, the gates,
the rats are our friends put the
skulls out. Well, what is interesting?
What are those various sizes of them?
They'd go up to about two pounds
in New York City to have a,
he doesn't think there's any that are
three because they'd be too big to be able
to move around physiological
limit to their size. Does
it say how long they live?
Average? About two years. One to
two years in the wild, up to four.
If you have it as a pet.
A wow. That's it. Yeah.
My wife had hamsters alert that my wife
had rats for pets when she was a kid.
Was she golf now?
She was just like Jersey kid just loved
animals and she would just ride her bike
around in this rat would just be
like on her shoulder. Jesus Christ.
We're grat lady. Weird. Yeah.
Yeah. I get it. What it was,
but she said they were super smart and
super affectionate. Yeah. If you had it,
it's a whole life and you raise it right?
Yeah. Why not? Yeah. It's not dirty.
It's not like going through the sewers
and Eaton Poo and climate on your hand.
Right.
But it would have just let it go.
Maybe 100% she like had
it out with her go rat.
Like if you just let it let it loose in
the wild, how long would it take for?
How long would it take for a domesticated
rat to adapt to living in like a New
York City sewer? 40 seconds.
What do you think they were?
Do they just get their crazy fucking
Disney may look at you from the suburbs
where he'd been living in
a house? Yeah, with like,
you know those are the multi colored rats.
They have like all these little
different colors on them. Oh,
you so clean with your pink
hair. Different colors. Look,
hey Joe, get a load of this
one. He's not even Greg. Hey,
how come you ain't Greg? Look
at Julia White. You're brown.
You're like a fucking dog
over there. Thank you. Better
than us, don't ya? Yeah. Hey,
get over here. I guess you don't
know how to get into the restaurant.
What do you got money on you?
You give us some money,
we'll show you where you
get all the good food. Yeah.
You ever been a little Italy?
We till the show yet. What up?
It's a shore dives. Getting born
a rap. Being born or at oh. Oh,
the worst. Terrible. Nobody likes you.
No one likes you, but you will. I have a,
you do survive pretty well. You'd
be better off being a hab. Alina.
What's a half Alina? It's a
peccary. What's a peccary?
It's like a cousin to a pig.
What's a pig
you ever see that lead Doug lives? You
know Doug lives in Bisbee, Arizona.
Stan hope. Um, oh, by the
way, I think it's so, it's
sold out, but he's taping his,
uh, his next special in Vegas
next month. Oh, nice. Yeah.
In Vegas. That's cool. Where he lives in
Bisbee like he basically, that's Avalina.
He lives really close to the border.
Like I think he's the only,
like six miles from the border
or some crazy shit. Um, and um,
these things live in the wild,
out in the desert, right?
Fucking there are aggressive and
they fucked up his neighbor's dog.
They killed his neighbor's dog. Yeah, man,
the dog was out and the Havoline is will
flank it looked to get on both sides of
it and they, they uh,
like in a pack. Yeah.
They hunt in the pack and
they will attack a small dog
that thinks disgusting. Gross.
That's, that's like a giant rat.
It looks like a giant rat. Well, it
does look so it looks like a pig.
Fucked her raw. Somebody shot
in the face. Oh, crossbow.
People hunt them all the time. It
looks like a pig. Fucked a rat. I see.
That got shot. One doesn't go get pink.
Fucked around, right? It does. Yeah.
Click on the guy who shot
one. Yeah. Bow and Arrow.
A lot of guys a hunt down
with archery equipment. See,
wouldn't it be better if he was
dressed in like a doe coat with a tie?
None of those boots. You don't want
that thing to see you look at that.
That's a rat face
picture.
Giant body screw. Scroll back to that
last one and make it bigger. Yeah. Yeah.
Bra.
That guys hunting rats.
That's like a slightly
different looking rat. Oh,
you want to know what's really
crazy? Giant rat. That's
a hundred pound rat. Yeah.
Without a tail.
It's so gross.
And you know what's really crazy
is those were animals. Um, they'll,
they're the best animal to a call now.
What a call is,
is like you'd made up make a sound of
a wounded animal. No, you make like,
like something that's stopped suffering.
Look like people take their hand,
these fuckers run in,
they run in gas,
they're so aggressive. It's
crazy to watch. Something's
hurting. I can go eat it.
They,
but they have to act quick because there's
coyotes out there and mountain lions
out there. So when something's
hurting you're like fuck food.
And they just run towards it.
So when your bow hunting,
you almost have to have one person make
the call and you're at full draw and
then they start calling and the things
come running in and you shoot at him.
Yeah.
Cause you couldn't do it.
You couldn't get to the boat for a long
time because they'd see you and they go
fuck it. The guy took off
the other way again. Yeah.
Are these like invasive where they all
over his property? No, they're natural.
They're there,
but I mean are they not invasive?
But I mean these are a lot of them. Yes.
There's like a ton of where exists. Yeah.
I mean they exist in the desert.
I mean,
they exist in healthy enough populations
that you, people hunt for them. Wow.
And they eat them. They say it takes you.
Yeah. It was neat that you eed to pig.
Yeah, but they're cuter. Wild boar.
Yeah. Crazy tusks looking. Yeah,
those are gross too. Pretty
gross to my pigs. My kings.
I believe those are the ones I have.
Bow ties climbing around this
guy's garage and little tap shoes.
Sometimes I had do this shit
down, Bro. They're standing.
I'm down there in his garage.
There's a whole bunch of 'em. Fuck.
Is that all right on your kid's toy?
Look at is.
It's all it's hair's up is running way.
Look at that.
Just going to take a
dump in your driveway.
Who'd you do not want that in your life?
I don't want to live there.
This fucking 20 of them in this guy's
driveway. See that one there and the back.
How many do you roll that back again?
How many were there?
There was like 12 what is
the name of that video for?
People want to watch it wild. Have
Aleena's make a visit to Arizona home.
Why? No, no, no. I know
you can't show it though.
Those fucking things are everywhere.
There's a lot of them we feel while
many of them there are at least at least
eight. And then there's the one that
was on top of the, there's nine.
And then there's the one
that was on top of the truck.
And that is one that you could
see through the fence. Yeah.
And there's probably more out there too.
It was gone in the car.
It's going into the kids.
A little car. Jesus Christ.
It's in the passenger seat of the car.
Gross.
Fucking creepy. Like wild. Have Alina is
like a Dean Martin Song. Do you think so?
Look at all over there.
Look at, Oh fuck man.
They're weird looking too.
They look like they're demons.
I don't like them at all. A little
beady eyes like they're up to. No. Good,
but if he was a little kid,
you thinking like,
I wouldn't live there because
that's there. But if you
live in New York at night,
who knows what's climbing all around?
Your building could be eagles and shit.
Right? Is that what you talking about?
No.
Google.
I get into my house and a
Google Havoline it eats baby.
Let's see if that's ever
happened. Yeah. Human Baby.
Let's see if that happened. What do you
think if I have a of eight a human? Yeah,
like she, those fucking things.
20 in that guy's drought.
They definitely eaten babies.
I'm exaggerating.
It wasn't 20 someone's
eating the baby right now.
Probably 13 it was probably 12 Baker's
dozen. A Baker's dozen of heaviness.
Yeah. They would eat a baby. A
toddler. Yeah. Knock it down. Yeah.
I mean if they eat a dog, yeah,
they're scared of people. Obviously.
We weren't scared of that dude.
Now that's a full brown person
and the baby doesn't end.
It doesn't have anything. I know. I put
his hair up, spikes up to let you know.
It's threatened to ever tell you the
story. When I pulled a rabbit out of my,
uh, pull vacuum. Yeah.
Was it alive? No. Did Stink.
It had it stunk. I'm like, why isn't the
vacuum working? Did you think about it?
I dove in and I pulled it up
and there was a half a rat.
It's ass sticking out the vacuum.
And as soon as I got it
above the water flies, just
pull it out without it.
There's a quest. She king.
Where the fuck are the flies
before the shit? Good question.
Where the fuck are they all over
there? Not that many. Like if you,
if you are around by a person's
backyard. Yeah. How often he's,
he flies every now and then there's one,
it's kind of annoying,
but if you just pulled your pants down,
shat on the ground,
it would be flies on that
within a matter of moments. Oh,
you mean right after I swam, you swam
the shaft right on their law. I mean,
you're after swim shit. Yeah. And then
all of a sudden they show up. Yeah.
It's disgusting. It
happened so fast. So gross.
All of a sudden they're all like,
yeah, like where'd you guys come from?
We should just stay inside a little.
Did you find a baby death from of have
Alina a couple of months ago. It's not.
A couple people in Arizona were attacked
and they had like old woman was bit
while she was walking her dogs and other
guy was bit while he was feeding them
and he didn't feed it fast
enough and it bit them.
That's about as much sacrifice.
Well the lady who got bit,
that's the scary one because the
guy who fed them as an asshole.
Right. This Gary one. That's it.
There was a lady got bit by
a coyote recently in Dallas
though. Yeah, no, no. Yeah,
it was around the Dallas area.
I think they think that there's just
one coyote that's been biting people.
It's a rogue,
unusual coyote snapping at people.
Yeah. They had bite marks on their
legs. Oh my God, that's gross man.
Cause they will kill you. They
would kill you. They're just small.
They're just not sure if it's worth
the effort and you're around people and
they're worried that you know.
One on one cause you fight off a coyote.
I don't know if you could then, I mean I
think you probably could if you had to,
but they'll fuck you up man. Just
keep buying it. There's a few of them.
That's where the real problem comes. If
they bite you in the right spot. Yeah man,
the rip your tendons apart.
You won't be able to run away.
They know what they're doing to, you know,
they know what they're doing. It though.
Did try to take your legs out.
I mean they know what they're doing.
They're not going to try to jump
up and bite you in the neck.
They're going to try to take your,
your hamstrings out trying to rip
your legs apart so you can't run.
Why are they so mean?
That's how they're alive.
You're not leaving any food
out for them or you know,
you've got to do what they gotta do.
It's called domestication.
That's how we have dogs. Do you ever take
your family camping? I have not. Yeah.
I haven't either.
I would though.
I wanted to take my kids to Yosemite cause
I love Yosemite to bring a peace sign
arm.
Nothing just went solo.
We weren't camping and we were staying
in it and we were staying in an end.
What about emergency food?
No morale. Iphone, nothing.
Just a phone. First Aid kit.
Nothing.
Bag of Funyuns and an iPhone.
So I need,
and I want to show them you'll 70 cause
it's such a great part of my life.
I love it. I've been living in the
back country for like a week at a time.
I just love the whole thing and I telling
them about it and I'm building it up.
They would be like, you know, but
grudgingly going. They're all vegetarians.
They just love nature. They
just love whatever. So I'm like,
you're going to love Yosemite is as we
drove into the park, welcome to Yosemite.
I ran over a squirrel.
The horror inside the car.
Dad, you didn't even slow down.
What's wrong? You're a monster.
I'm like I can't. It's two lanes.
There's a guy behind me, a guy front.
I just would steamroll the squirrel.
They were so they were in
the whole weekend. Anytime.
I'd be like, look at this.
Look at this beautiful view.
You killed a squirrel.
You didn't even care. That's the weird
part. Dang. You didn't even care.
Is that what they're saying?
Yeah, we were supposed to cry.
I was just laughing like a bitch.
Yeah, exactly. That's what he did.
He killed a or you'd be sadder, right?
Right. Yeah. Well I can't, damn,
I can't believe that
she is.
She was so nice to their little eyes and
little tail, but it's square a peccary.
Yeah. If you can't win them Havalinas
like he's fucking rat thing. Fine.
It's mom that have Avalina would ruin
your, that punch to bite your teeth.
He'd probably use it's t
to tear your tires apart.
Then you be stuck in the side of
the road trying to change a tire.
You turn around, there's a whole
pack of them closing in on you.
Would you not take your
family because of all of this?
Do you not want them
in the woods with you?
What am I a danger in the woods or
become a werewolf? What the fuck?
He just got to stay tonight.
Trust me. I'll be right back.
Not that you're the threat,
Ron,
that you'd have to protect them
from all the threats. Well,
I mean Yosemite doesn't have that
many threats other than people bears.
They have black bears then.
Yeah.
Most of Mountain Lion
Mountain lions are an issue.
There's always something out there.
Yeah. Grizzly bears or you're just for,
you just don't feel like that's a cause.
You like going out into nature,
you go do all that stuff. I do like one
of the nature also, like being indoors,
like sleeping in a place
where it's awesome to sleep.
People wiser than me if figured it out
that that maneuver is called a bed with a
roof and a locked door and a refrigerator.
You fucking cave person.
Oh, I'm going to rough it. I'm gonna
Sleep on the ground. You don't have to,
you know that I can sleep in a house.
Yeah, but when you go hunting and stuff,
don't you sleep in the woods sometimes?
Most of the time, no. I'm going to have,
oh you don't. You go back to
[inaudible]. What? What guys I go with.
Go with Steve Rinella.
We always almost always go camping
except for one were at our friend Doug
Durrance place,
which is a,
he lives in Wisconsin and he's got a
giant farm and we hunt deer on a hundred
year on there. And uh, that
place he's got a cool little,
little like a deer hunting house.
Oh yeah, that's near the s yeah,
like a cabin. It looks like a house. It's
like a house, a small house at everybody.
A look. Hangs out in different spots
there. Yeah. Right, right, right.
I'd like to take my kids camping.
There's something nice about sleeping
in the woods and shorter in nature.
You know what else is cool?
Not getting eaten. Hbo
Take a shower in the morning.
That's nice. Yeah. You got go stove,
coffee. That's the big thing.
Yeah. Yeah. Look, I put up,
there's nothing better than a campfire.
I now hanging out,
especially at the end of a long day of
hiking, and then you've got a campfire,
and if you get one of those little grates
over the campfire, you start cooking,
Cook over the campfire. That's
the bass, the best things in life.
I know and I feel like my kids
don't have that connection cause uh,
do you worry about being with them
in the woods? Yeah, a little bit.
If anybody gets hurt, it's hard to get
out. Yeah. And just that, you know,
it's like if you and I went, we're both
responsible for, we'd help each other out,
but I'm going to leave. Get your act
together. What? I'm going to leave you.
I'm sorry. What? I'm going to leave you
say that again. Yeah. I just, I can't,
I cannot tell you guys
planning a camping trip like,
hey, we're going to look out for each
other. I'm going to leave you behind.
I'll tell you right now, it looks you
on my leg camera with you, but I'm not,
I can't handle any adversity. I
will fall apart. Please don't.
Where are you going?
And we're not going in too far.
I will walk one mile when the
alarm goes off at one mile camp.
Dude, seriously, you're
not going to help me out.
I'll call somebody when I get there.
He's back there or mile. I don't know,
something like a mile.
Just follow the blood.
He's got a backpack full of Slim Jim's.
It'd be all right. It'll be good.
He's got enough food on. Well, I
left him one liter of my pis. Uh,
he can drink that.
Just got his leg where I peed.
Horrible camping and commanding.
I got good news and bad news.
The bad news is I don't have any water.
The good news is I have to pee.
So what do you want to do it one day?
I mean to fill up your Nalgene
bottle. Oh, awful to know. But you're,
but if you go with your
kids and you're like,
you're responsible for everybody and
everything and yeah, it's pretty, yeah,
maybe just a hike.
Well,
there's nothing wrong with camp when
the kids a good idea. Just, you know,
you should,
if you really aren't going to go camping,
you definitely should bring first aid
and definitely brings a satellite phone
and you can camp in places that, you
know, you're not back country a mile in.
You could just, you know, pull up,
walk 200 feet off a fucking airstream son.
Pull that bitch behind park.
Turn the generator on satellite TV.
Yeah,
that would be fun. Stores.
You can rent those and just
talk to her.
Yelling out the window.
Making friends.
I think uh, I would like to like load
them up in a RV kind of situation.
Go see the Grand Canyon. Go through
Utah. Like Chevy Chase. Yeah. Yeah.
I think that we're going to be fun.
Two more people just died in the
Grand Canyon. What fell? Yeah. Really?
Why they're not just reading the railings?
I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
I just read two more people just fell to
their death in the Grand Canyon. Really?
Let's see. If you find out
what's going on, why are people,
that was one of the first hikes I did
with my father. We do in the switchbacks.
What'd you say, Jim? If
there's a reason why I say,
well I'm a guy who's got too close and
slipped and I need to know what I slipped
off the stop falling. If I had
Google glass, I didn't know.
And already if I had that memory link
wire thing that Jamie's worried about,
Jamie's going to be the
first one to get it.
Then he's going to like organize to
make sure that no one else gets it.
My thought on that too was like,
who is going to be the first one
to get it and how you decide that?
Well for sure like money,
Marcus Brownley and
Lou from unbox therapy,
they'll get it first and they'll put it
on and then they'll start running the
world and they go, ah, no
one else gets this dope.
But Mark Zuckerberg probably already
has it. You don't want to it right now.
Fend his case.
Yeah. It's um, it's coming. Something's
coming. Yeah, man. What's it gonna be?
Who knows what's going to be,
something's coming and something's going
to be more invasive than what we're
experiencing now,
so I can be sure of.
They're going to figure how to
get more and more data. You know,
Sam Harris has a really
interesting podcast. It's out.
It's either the one that's going on,
right?
Maybe the two weeks ago. And it was
all about, I should probably find it.
It was all about um,
privacy,
privacy and what's the difference between
the way a different tech companies
approach privacy and actually it makes
you respect how apple does it. Oh yeah,
yeah. I mean they apparently
they do it much more. Um,
I guess the word would be
there more ethical about it.
They're trying not to give away any
trouble with Facebook is what it's called.
I was reading a thing
yesterday that you know,
you put those a doorbell things on,
you know like ring,
you know the records, people coming
up to you and they said, you know,
you think it's cool for you and your
family but the ups guy or all these
delivery people that are getting their
picture taken and sent to a database
every day, right? Like these people
are being monitored all the time.
So while it's good for you,
it's not that great for these
other people that visit you.
This guy's name is Roger Mcnamee. That's
the one, it's the trouble of Facebook.
It's episode one 52. It's really,
it's very interesting cause the,
what what goes into is about how tech
companies figured out how to tap into a
resource that no one thought of.
And that resource is your data
and how much is that worth? Well,
it turns out it's worth
fucking untold billions.
It's one of the most valuable things
cause it you can direct market to people.
You could find out what people are
in tune with or not and to you get,
you get a lot of people
that you can get ahold of.
And we kind of gave our consent to
this without understanding it. Yeah.
And they got in through a loophole
and this is how they're able to make,
you know,
ungodly amounts of money
just because we wanted to have that cool
feature. So you just say, yeah, here's,
take it from me.
Maybe thinking about the amount of money,
something like Facebook brings in
versus what it is. Like what is it?
What are you doing? What are you
doing this making all that money.
They're providing people with data,
you know,
and they're also getting people to the,
it's like a,
an ongoing psychological experiment
in what makes people engage.
Like what makes people comment more?
Turns out it's anger. Oh really? Yeah.
It turns out that what makes people
engaged the most is things they disagree
with when they started having fights,
fights back and forth.
So you get people to get really
into these polarizing subject,
right? And then you, once they
start looking for those subjects,
then they'll subject starts showing up
in their feet since all sorts of things
that they get angry about. So then they
started interacting with these things.
The more you interact, the more more it
shows up in your feed and all the wild,
they're profiting on enraging you.
I'm like God,
I mean this is essentially what they do.
She creepy Facebook patent uses image
recognition to scan your personal photos
for brands.
Oh my God.
Yeah. So they just take all your photos
and I'll collect dorito bags in the back.
Applying computer vision algorithms
to user uploaded multimedia objects to
detect specific objects
within the multimedia object
and promoting the uploaded
multimedia object from a user's news
feed to a sponsored stories area.
That's what the patent
was awarded for. Ah, Jeez.
A little vision content
detection for sponsored stories.
Wow,
that's crazy man.
Yeah.
You snap a selfie sipping a Unicorn
frappe at Starbucks and then shares that
selfie on Facebook or Instagram.
Facebook's newly patented technology
can theoretically scan the photo,
spot the Starbucks cup with the help of
an image object recognition algorithm
and then sell that info to Starbucks.
Alerting the coffee giant of the
fact that you like it's product.
Well,
they're already doing a version of that
with your search things you're looking
at. You know when you go through their
browser, they're already doing that.
Well,
they're doing it also with voice.
Your phone is listening to you all the
time. If you have Alexa in your home,
it's listening. My kids and
when we, we do it all the time,
like if you're talking about something
and then all of a sudden you see,
I was performing in Boise and so we
were talking about Boise, Boise, Boise,
and then everybody on their Instagram
was getting an ad for vacationing and
Boise. See, that seems
gesture must speaking it.
That seems like a really serious thing.
It is.
It seems like a really serious thing
that everybody is just like, oh,
this is happening. Yeah. I
remember signing off on this.
The technology is ahead of our anger
or our recognition of it. Yeah.
We don't understand.
Yeah.
It's already happened by the
time you're upset that it
exists, right? Yeah. It's, it's in
full full force right now. Yeah.
Yeah. It's really weird. It's really
weird. It's really weird. I mean,
we're just talking about it. This is just,
we think it's, you're just in your home.
You were in a private place, but these
phones that are just listening, you know,
and again, this is something that
didn't exist 10 ago, 15 years ago.
Did these concerns didn't exist. What
would be the concerns 15 years from now?
Look how much more invasive as is going
to get before we even recognize that
it's happening. Because this
is, this is something, the, the,
the listening in on things is something
that people didn't think about before it
happened. Now they know it does. Well,
the face recognition thing is there's a
lot of articles on that and how that we
don't realize, well, they're trying
to think. Totally makes sense. Right.
Especially with so many people's phones
use face recognition software. Right.
With the Samsung phones have it, you know,
my, my galaxy note nine has it. Yeah.
I phones have it. Yeah. And you're
psyched about it. You're just like, oh,
that's cool. I don't have to
put in my password anymore.
It's just look at it now I'm in my app.
They also have one that's
an iris scanner on the note.
The note scans your irises.
Oh, really? Wow. Borough.
It's quick too. It looks at your eyeballs
like, Yep. Yeah. You, she do, you know,
man, what does that say, Jamie?
I was trying to find it the
first time you brought up,
but I know that there's these masks
that exist that are in quotes like hyper
realistic masks and that can be used to,
I don't know if it's this,
this and it's used to
help the face recognition,
but I think people are using them to trick
it and do fake stuff and like not all,
if you could commit a robbery with that
on and just like having a ski mask on
now they just can't see her face.
But it'll thinks that right.
If you had a Hoodie on. Yeah.
What about in minority report?
Remember when they had to pull his eye,
they were selling eyeballs on the black
market for the eye scan to get into
buildings and staff to do with that is
put like a Bandana around your mouth.
Right? So it could, no one
could see your mouth moving.
Have that thing on your
sunglasses. Yeah, but my,
even my iPhone gets through my sunglasses.
I don't know how I know.
So let's face some recognition. So,
but what I'm saying is with this,
like if you wanted to rob someone and
have something like even the facial
recognition software would,
would think that it would legitimately
think you were somebody else.
Hopefully now.
And what about for when we're doing our
crowd and we were trying to rob us or
hopefully not moody guys.
Criminals.
That's crazy. It's kind of happen, but
it's so fast too. I mean, you know,
this is so new.
We're also the like the special effects
technology that allows people to make
faces the code.
Look how beautiful those things look
so close to a person of these for a 200
bucks. You could fly. One should do
it. Listen, I'm going to get you, oh,
I should buy you and then see if
I go open up your phone. Yeah,
that would be crazy. That
would be cool. That'd be crazy.
See if it can open up your phone.
Look super creepy.
But oh that's so weird.
Oh he looks like a demon.
If they can add a little late texted
or it could be moveable Kinda. Wow.
That looks pretty real though. I
mean, you know a little creepy,
but that looks pretty
accurate. That's crazy. Act.
I wouldn't look twice on the walking down
the street and even think about it now.
You'd be like, that guy has a good shave.
Sorry. Beautiful Person. A skin so smooth.
Your baby's bottom.
It was started off. That's my face.com
and it's not been switched to whatever.
This is your meeting surveillance.
That's just creepy. She's there.
Do you guys know, is there a problem
with doing like any of those, uh,
23 and me ancestry DNA,
bro. The government.
You're going to the Illumina and he's
going to check your fucking spit. Do they?
Is it bad to do? I don't
know. Should I do not do it?
What are they going to do with it?
How are they going to clone me, Bro?
If they want your DNA, they can get
it just by touching your clothes,
getting ahold of your stuff. They
can get ahold of you. They could,
they could find out all sorts of stuff
from hair samples right behind hair.
If you drink a Starbucks
and then they grab your cup,
they can get a DNA sample off your cop,
then someone can get your DNA sample
right. So it doesn't really matter.
So if I want to find out if I'm Greek or
Italian, she find out, I should find out.
It's pretty comprehensive. Have you done
it? Yeah, I've done it. Oh yeah. Yeah.
It's interesting. It gives you a lot
of other weird stuff too. Like um, uh,
that you might have certain genes that
for certain proclivities even including
like lactose intolerance, uh, propensity
to alcohol, really alcoholism.
Some super athletes have certain muscle
jeans you should find out if you have
those genes,
like power athletes,
like almost extraordinary number of ones
that are successful in certain sports.
Oh really? Yeah. A type of Jean or
does it, and it gives you all this,
so you have to specify this at all. It's
a really detailed report. Oh Wow. Yeah,
it's really detailed and covers
all sorts of different categories.
And it's cool too.
And you find out like weird stuff.
You know what part of Europe
your parents were from, you know,
maybe you have some Asian
in you didn't know you had.
It's, it's really cool. Yeah,
that's cool. It's cool.
It's, um, it's just,
it makes you really think like to
get here in 2019 what had to happen.
He all the people in the past and
if you keep going back, you know,
like I have a little bit of Asian in
me and it was like 1% or something like
that. But I think like where did that
come from? Like who, where was that?
Is that why you liked you?
Just to I don't think so.
I think a lot of people just like Jujitsu
Bro. Is that why he likes Sushi? Um,
I don't think it's that Asia, they come
from a different agent, but I don't know.
I think, um, I think, you know,
if you could show somebody though,
went through Asia and hooked up
with somebody. Yeah, for sure.
But what I'm saying is I think that if
you look at what technology was available
like 200 years ago for
finding the ancestry,
people didn't even know if that was
their kid 50 years ago. Right, exactly.
Two years ago he had a guest,
you know?
I mean maybe they had
paternity tests 50 years ago.
Did they like just trying to
find your roots back in Italy?
You just have to go find like town hall
and see if there's a book with your
great grandfather's name
in it. Yeah, but I mean,
you didn't know if your dad was really
your dad. If your mom was a hoe.
I knew that. I knew that around
sixth grade. I figured that out.
It's wanting to know a hundred years ago,
if you were the father of someone's child,
you to look at the kid and go,
the kid looks like me, or convince
yourself with the kid looks like,
or convince yourself the kid
just got your wife's features,
but it's still your kid right now.
You can actually get DNA test done and
be like, oh, you know what the coldest,
hardest shit is when you find
out that it's not your kid,
but you still have to pay child support
because you've been paying child support
and you still have to,
if the DNA confirms that he's not,
it's in different states.
There's different rules. But uh,
I believe that's how it is in California
and I believe that's how it is in
several other states where if, uh, it
turns out the young lady had strayed,
ah, no caught subside. Dick is a,
hey, hey, woo, got to go now.
You got to keep paying. Yeah. Who you
know, that's not gonna keep paying.
Even if you do a DNA test and you
find out the child's not yours,
I think once you have started paying,
unless you,
you might have to go to court and,
and Duke it out both.
I don't think your payment obligation
stops just because it's not your kid.
And what a weird shift to if like you
think it's this kid and you're supporting
them and then to beat
switching your head like, no,
I'm not going to help him anymore.
They didn't have testing really
until the 80s whoa. Yeah,
until the 80s Oh, it's a
whole new world. Oh No,
no.
[inaudible] was one of the first one that
people didn't really even believe it.
Remember? That's kind of how
I got on. Right. That's right.
And they started just see us saying
that they didn't know how to handle the
samples and they,
well there was some funkiness with
that two stepping all over it.
They didn't believe the one
in a trillion kind of numbers.
They were passing out of it.
Thank overzealous aggressive
like police and detectives.
I think that's common.
I think that's the short term it is.
Did you see that fucking video?
It happened. Tesla sentiment mode.
Did you see that shit? Now, you know,
Tesla is a century mode and it caught
some politician back in is escalate into a
model three scuffing it up,
getting out, looking at it,
trying to rub it out,
and then taking off.
And they called him up because they
could see his face in the video and they
knew who it was because this guy had
been like a kind of prominent politician.
And so, um, here it is. There's
those little, the little nick,
but they said it was like $2,000 to fix.
And when Jesus,
that's a lot of money for that,
a little nicotine,
it seems a little ridiculous little scuff.
Um,
so the dude just backs into
it and tries to jump. Yeah.
It's funny. Yeah. Bonk right
into the Tesla is the side.
It's always recording.
He just backed his stupid car.
Guy Just doesn't know how to drive.
He might've been drunk. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Look at him. Look,
sat down. Looks at it. All
right. You don't have to. Well,
he tried to fix it. He's in deep shit.
He tried to fix it. The fuck he did.
He did not, if when they
call them, oh they did cat.
And apparently that guy had already been
to jail for something else here. Dirty.
Yeah. He, uh, it's not good. It might be.
That's our map. I, um,
I bumped into someone's car once and I
left a note with my phone number and my,
uh, my address. Nice or not my
address, my phone number and my name.
And they called me up and they just so
happened to be very good friends with
someone who else runs with.
So then he calls me up and he tells me,
dude,
you hit my friend's car. I
go, tell him to call me, man.
It's cool. Yeah, it was
unthinkable. I, it wasn't bad,
but it was something, I was like, it
was a little scuff on the bumper. Right.
But it was my, it was, I was like,
oh, thank God I left a message.
I would feel like such a
piece of shit. Yeah, exactly.
I wrote my friend and he was like,
some fucking ass hole.
Hit my friend's car and took off. You
believe that shit. I'm like, no, crazy,
bro. That's, that's bullshit. And now
cameras have everybody doing everything.
So you'll always get busted.
Yeah.
When do you think it's going
to be where you have a Tesla?
You know what those things do?
When do you think it's going to be
where no one's driving? How many,
how many more years? Well, we're,
a lot of people aren't driving 20 I would
say 20 to 30 you remember when Prius
is where a joke someone had a preach to
like get that fucking stupid thing away
from me? Yeah. Or even the
early Tesla. The roadster. Like,
do you know that top gear you want to,
you know that British show top gear?
Here's what's crazy.
I found out they did an episode where
they pretended that the Tesla roadster
died on them while they were
driving around the track.
But it didn't really die on though.
That was just a storyline was they
wanted it to die. So it's gross.
Apparently the way the show is made,
it's like a comedy show and it's
scripted so they can get away with doing
something like that.
So Elon Musk's sued them
and I think he lost,
believe it or not,
cause they don't claim to be exactly.
They don't claim to be factual and
they complained. They, they don't,
they don't claim to not have
narratives. Right. They create. Cool.
So gross that up just to make
sure that I'm that grocery gross.
It's amazing how many
shots that they take.
Elan Musk called top gear completely
phony and his company sued for libel and
malicious false.
So it's a judge dismissed the suit in
October saying no view or the program
could have reasonably be compared the
roadsters performance on the track to real
world performance on the street. That
seems fuzzy. I don't know what that means.
Okay. What is um, 2012
that one. What is the case?
What did he said?
What Elon Musk said that it was,
that they faked it and they
claimed the power Tesla for, okay,
let's see what it says. We
could figure out, I think,
I'm pretty sure that's the story.
After Tessa dropped the car off,
Elon Musk claimed that one of his
employees was along for the delivery.
Notice that a script for the episode
inside there was a segment about the Tesla
breaking down,
but that was only the tip of the iceberg.
Top gear claim that the Tesla roadster
ran out of power while driving after just
55 miles, much less than the 200
miles quartered by Tesla all be it.
It was being driven hard. A claim that
Musk said was untrue. According to him,
the roads,
there's logs show that the car had
never dipped below 20% charge during the
entirety of the filming. The clip followed
with the roadsters motor overheating,
which wasn't addressed by mosque.
And finally a break failure,
which must claims was instead a blown
fuse and not an equipment failure.
Battery powered electric cars
will soon die altogether.
Former top care host James Mason.
Ah, interesting. Isn't it
amazing? So there was something,
sounds like there was
some horseshit for sure,
but it does sound like there was a real
break problem and the brake problem was
a blown fuse, which there's
nothing you can do about that,
but just that he hates such a
strange thing that like, yeah,
you just have to attack electric
cars. Like it's just a, well,
I think the wem them making a script.
If they had a script that said that
the test was going to break down,
they thought it was be funny.
It's a comedy. It's a comedy show.
Jeremy Clarkson was fucking
hilarious. He's really funny. Yeah.
But there is definitely people that are,
yeah.
You believe a lot of the stuff that
they say and the performance of the car.
I would, you know, I always
thought it was funny,
but I also saw them as experts.
Well, they kind of are.
I mean, they know a lot of shit. Yeah.
They know a lot of shit about cars,
for sure. Jeremy Clarkson,
he knows a lot about cars.
The problem is people go to them for
advice and lap times and all that shit.
And if you're saying it, cars breaking
down and you, you engineered that script,
it's pretty dirty. It is dirty. Well,
that's how like Sean Hannity gets away
with saying that he's not a news program.
Does he get away with that? So it's a
WWE of news. He says it's a, it's a,
it's entertainment really.
He says, yeah. Yeah. Oh,
do you have a little, a little out. We're
not a news program. We don't claim to be.
He says that.
Yeah.
Although a lot of people are
coming to teeth thinking it's news,
but isn't he a commentary program?
Isn't that what they say? Oh,
he's not that. He's new. He says
it's entertainment. Oh yeah. Do you,
do you find entertaining?
No. No. I should just say,
oh, I could do this as it's
entertaining. He's a liar. He,
it's not that entertaining.
I didn't find it entertaining.
I'm going to sue them and the
game of Thrones people tracking
those aren't real drag dope as fuck.
Did you watch last night? I didn't.
I did was again, spoiler alert.
It was awesome. Oh yeah. Awesome.
Just to see everything. I just want to
see it. I was happy to see a new episode.
I'm going to be so sad when that
show gets canceled. I'm such a Dork.
You've watched it all the way out and
about doing the prequel or the beginning
of it worry series, but
they haven't come. Amen.
Whoever the fuck of people other than
doing it. You just keep doing things.
Whoever those people that are writing
and producing it and putting it together
and keep hiring those actors to
play different people. I don't care.
I lost my way after like maybe three
seasons. How many seasons is it benign?
Like five. Fuck up. You lost your way.
Go back and start from scratch and learn
all the names of these places and the
make believe thing.
Whatever's,
how much do I have to know, Joe? I
know what you know how to make bread.
Just keep making a dish is bread.
I do keep it simple.
A Martini, a little bread. Little
run. It live your life. Yeah. Jog.
How much? Why do I have to do
I have to control everything?
I would like to nef. Oh,
catch back up with it. Yeah,
it's good. Right? People like you.
So you're going to like let this whole
season play by without you being caught
up. I F I almost last night it was just
going to watch just jumpers jump in.
Who cares if I show that you never get
like please tell me you gave up on the
walking dead. Yes. Thank you.
Yeah, I stopped that one.
Is there any show that you haven't
given up on that you've been steadfast?
That I stay. What? I mean you binge then
you still watch, uh, you haven't quit?
No, there's none that I'm currently
watching. I just watched Russian doll.
What does that, that's on
Netflix? That was good.
That girls like an assassin or
something? No, she's, she's uh,
she dies every episode. It's like
groundhog day. Yeah. It was pretty good.
And uh, no, I've seen all the big ones.
The Ozark Ozaki a one season of it.
Do you didn't watch season two?
Was I supposed to?
I don't know how you just shut it off.
You don't want to know what happened?
I don't know.
I forget.
It's already forget. Fuck.
It's already three o'clock,
three o'clock in the afternoon and
the time fly in this conversation.
Did we start? When did
we start? 1230 1230 yeah,
something like that. Three
o'clock a telephone people
where you're at? My brother.
I am a,
I'm going to Boston.
I'm going to North Hampton. We
doing in Boston. A city winery. Ooh.
What is that? It's this
elegant winery place. Right.
And they have stand up and stand up
there. Wow. Mostly bands. No Shit.
Yeah. Okay. Doing a bunch of those kinds
of, it's actually a winery or real winery.
Ah, yeah. They make their own wine.
Whoa. In Boston. That's cool. Yeah.
It's really cool. My friend had been
there before at a winery once. I was like,
this is the coolest shit ever. Yeah.
It's pretty cool. I'm going to do Napa.
I'm going to do something up in
Napa and other wine spot. Yeah.
That's where they were. Oh
yeah. They were up in now,
but he's a nice theater that I've
done. Yeah. Yeah. That's a good spot.
It's that whole area is amazing. Right?
The food, there's all, it's amazing.
It's no joke.
They know that place.
They've got it so dialed in the wines.
Amazing.
The nature's amazing. Brian Cowen,
we're up there with those hunting guys.
We were fleeing Turkey hunting
episode and uh, Brian Callen and I,
after we went Turkey hunting, these guys
went back to this a airbnb they rented.
They were like, guys, they
had like hamburger and shit
like this. I would guys,
these are the best restaurants
in the world. And they're
right here. Like, c'mon,
let's go out. I'll pay, you know what? No
one's through whom, mic? Cheeseburgers.
Callen and I went out, like, gentlemen,
we've got to find bottle Weiss Turkey
hunting and clinking fine glasses.
Come on and eating a delicious,
amazing,
incredible food. And we had a wonderful
time there. There's certain types,
certain people, you know, they figured it
out over time. They've got it dialed in.
Just do what they do. Do Ya.
But it's good to appreciate it.
It's good to appreciate it. Oh, 100%.
It's good. If you ate there every day,
I think it would be, no, it's a treat.
It's something. Yeah, it means something.
And then you'll remember that
dinner. You know, it's not like just,
we were just mocking those guys
the entire time. Drinking wine.
Get let talk at Shit. Having
fun. That's one of the best,
coolest things about having a friend
like Cowan who was just always funny.
Everywhere you go. Come on buddy. You're
my one man comedy show and then, you know,
he's holding wine, making some
shit up and just pontificating.
And then he's hilarious. He
is. He really makes me laugh.
Um,
so website Tom,
papa.com [inaudible] dot com Tom Papa on
the Instagram, Tom pop on the Twitter.
All of those things. My books go into a
paperback. She next month. Louisa's yeah,
it's very cool. It's all good.
Oh, he's great to be here.
Was great to have you going to get me
some milk on the way out. I brought my,
I brought up the old series or bag.
Yeah. Beautiful. Alright, bye everybody.